[Music]
foreign
no why are you doing so much hate in
your heart i'm so good at catching
things
you are weirdly good at catching like
you know i think it's just you
learning constantly being on the
infrared no i think it's you learning
reflexes from trying to
never let come hit your face why is that
something i should be embarrassed about
emily's such a loser she doesn't like
come here in the eye
i do like shaming people for things that
they should be proud of
oh i've never had a pearl necklace my
family's never had a pearl necklace
loser
she never had the shocker yeah no shit
oh gosh i'm a little bit loopy i'm not
going to lie i'm also going to take a
pro panel all uh right now because i
forgot that
i hadn't taken one walk us through what
that is um
you you don't you google it we're not
i'm not doing this anymore i'm not doing
the thing
where if you have a question you ask me
it's called a conversation i know if
it's easily found on google
don't ask me that's the new my new thing
okay
okay haven't we talked about creative
blockers on the show
no oh okay good can you google it and
then tell people what it is
i've i've got to go into podcasts or if
someone asks me a question i'm like
google and they're like
this is a fucking podcast your guest is
like
the new version of my podcast is just me
a bunch of bullet points of things for
you guys to google
and then you just sit here you know why
this i did that because i feel like i'm
a broken record and i talk about things
too much but if i haven't talking about
literally the one thing that you haven't
talked about
i'll give you a list of everything no
one wants to hear about anymore that is
not on it
okay here's the thing beta blockers um
well i'm going to have to start with
ancestral trauma
no okay and she's redoing a hotel in
west virginia
propanol is what it's called beta
blockers these are these things that if
you're nervous you can take them and
it's not like a um a narcotic
or a benzodiazepine like the other stuff
she's on or like i'm not on anything
else everyone still thinks that i'm like
on stuff i was during the pandemic i was
micro dosing a couple things but those
days uh are over
because my lover uh set a very strong
boundary that he would leave if i didn't
stop
just a small boundary and he was like
just a small background
fully consistently gotten back to
brushing your hair
well you when it's this um dry and
bleached
to wash it it's just like touch it
god fine let me touch it near the
microphone smr here get up and do it
over here then just because
i'm not going to lean over and tweak my
back for your weird perversions
hold on
we have fun we have fun bambi we have
that's our new
i did just uh try to
that's the sound of my hair oh my god
i'm wearing that also that is
by the way i just learned how you
masturbate a hundred percent the way she
just moved her hands
they're a little short it's like most
people masturbate like a lot
they're like tiny little quick fire yeah
um okay you wanted to know about
propanol and now i need to finish this
okay so when you are nervous you're
going to a job interview you are going
to an audition you are going to
a big pitch you have to do some public
speaking you're going to run into your
ex
at a party anything like that where you
are going to be sweating and you know
when you get nervous
as soon as you realize you're nervous it
you get more nervous
oh my god no i'm sweating and then
they're like oh now i'm nervous
everyone's gonna know i'm nervous
and then it's just this sort of cycle
that exacerbates and gets worse and
worse so
all beta blockers do is stop adrenaline
i should take one
every morning okay well you should i
mean the fact that you don't go through
my purse is shocking to me
um because there is a plethora i don't
take them as much as i used to i used to
do for like big auditions or big like
screen tests because a lot of times when
you're
in uh showbiz uh go into like a big
screen
test with like someone and then there's
a famous actor
like that you didn't know was going to
be there right big producer and it's
just it's more the fact that you're
thrown off
right like one time i went into an
audition for just like like a normal
sitcom
this is by the time celebrities started
like producing tv shows and i walked in
it was just like will smith was like two
feet away from me
and it was just like a it was just made
me nervous that would turn my armpits
into
faucets and it's not even so much about
him it's just more i am such a control
freak and you're like have i always had
hands what do i do i know
totally and i'm like i'm i'm like well
not fresh prunes like i'll say something
dumb you're like this is a story all
about how yeah i just can't i
like i when i'm nervous i say dumb
things and then i try to make jokes that
are bad and then i get more nervous
because i'm like oh god i'm never gonna
work again and i'm right
uh so that's why she started a podcast
this is not like zan i don't do xanax i
don't do any of that um
what are the other ones um like uh
narcolepsy the ones that make you
no that's i don't do codeine or whatever
the ones that are just to relax you yeah
i can't do any of that this just takes
away adrenaline it doesn't make you less
sharp it doesn't make you
tired it sounds amazing all it does yeah
it's a miracle and i give it to everyone
i even take it sometimes before i go to
sleep after shows because i'm like riled
up
or anxious just to stop because i will
produce adrenaline before i go to bed
yeah because either i'll look at my
phone and see some nightmare or look at
the news and spin myself out
or i'll be lying there and i'm like i'm
never gonna fall asleep
i only so i just take a beta blocker it
like stops that cycle for me but i'm
also on prozac
so find the cocktail that's right for
you speaking of
publicly speaking and yoking it's not a
joke
i mean not only am i doing a new hour of
material i'm also fully disrobing at the
end of every show
because i i'm so desperate for like
physical contact
and like touching people and now that
everyone's either vaccinated or has it
or whatever i'm just
going out there being a real perv
houston
i will be there this weekend doing a ton
of shows i love houston texas
um i was just about to say i'm staying
at the blank hotel
that was a wild instinct yeah if you
want to touch her
in person irl illegally with a very
sharp knife
come to where i'm staying then i'm going
to be in austin texas i'm doing a couple
shows in austin they're not big
shows i'm doing um the creek in the cave
it's called the sunset
strip these are just like last minute
like like book shows that are
i'm not doing a full hour i'm gonna do
uh theater in austin in the fall
then i'm gonna be in dallas addison
improv that's pretty much um sold out
uh thank you guys maybe we'll add some
shows tempe improv
is almost sold out uh the cb live in
phoenix i feel like those are i'm doing
cb live in phoenix and tempe improv
which are right next to each other
i think like three days apart so i feel
like everyone's buying tickets to one
but they don't even know i'm also in
phoenix um
uh go to the website yeah go to the
website you know what to do because i
want to complain
before we get to the brilliant brandon k
goodman my dear friend he's a writer on
big mouth we did a pilot together with
taylor tomlinson this year we got to
write together um
and uh it's a real he's a goddamn
delight goddamn delight
but because i i didn't want to bring
this toxic shit into his interview we're
just going to talk about this real quick
i'm just going to get this off my uh
very uh voluptuous silicone
chock full of silicone chest i
cannot with the elon musk why is
everyone so
obsessed with hating elon musk people
hate him people hate him but
but okay well why wouldn't what what
what why are what is this kink where
people go
i hate this guy now i know how you
masturbate i know but i did
uh well no i would have to have googled
myself so here's my thing about llamas
we got to just break this down real
quick because i can't
i can't keep uh having these
conversations with people because i
think it's just like he's the person at
the moment to hate
right right it seems like and i think
and a lot of the younger
people because i was talking to grace
who is 25 i'm like why do you hate this
guy so much she's like on first dates i
ask guys what they think of elon musk if
they like him i'm like out like she's
bragging about
dates 25 and she dates
great and so uh no i mean she's 25 so
it's probably the dates where you know
you think you're meeting the guy
and you show up and he has like nine of
his friends with him
thank you so they can all check you out
it's perfect
it's called the bachelor so her biggest
thing is that he was not self-made
people think that he comes from like
apartheid money maybe that's true
right i'd have to get more but he you
found out some information right
yeah he like came into canada with like
twelve hundred dollars in his pocket
worked on a farm
whether it's true or not whether it's
true or not we don't stand by anything
we say a lot of people that are
successful are not self-made this whole
thing of like in order to be famous you
have to be self-made
oh my gosh here might emily's
emily is a bird just got back from the
vet oh my gosh sorry
that was either an alarm in my house or
a bat we can't figure out which one
so um very few people are self-made i
can't stop fighting
like i can't fight anymore with people
about this from people like well he's
you know comes from a rich family
everyone that at this point that is that
has a famous actor a famous person had
to have come from money in order to
bankroll
their hobby which then turned into a
career i'm not happy about
it but like you know i i really googled
this because i wanted to be able to
defend this
okay nick cage his family were the
coppola family his uncle was
uh uh francis ford coppola i know he's
there were plenty of people that were
probably could scream just as weirdly
as nick cage who didn't have the access
because they didn't have the family
connections
paltrow came her mom was a famous
actress and director
anderson cooper is a vanderbilt that's
dude
one of the richest families in the
country
tucker carlson comes from the swanson
chicken empire chicken empire
chicken broth that's chicken broth money
baby and
um julia louie dreyfus brilliant dad was
a
billionaire like a financier um and look
me i'm sure i could also argue that
coming from that kind of family
is weird and creepy like i mean army
hammer stuff
like and maybe i'm not saying it means
you're safer or your life is better you
have different i mean
becoming really funny is oftentimes a
reaction to trauma so who knows what
julia
louis dreyfus you know maybe she had to
work hard for attention or maybe she
whatever right
like it's not why you're gifted you know
but that's why you're able to pursue
your gifts right and there's a lot of
people in new york which is like
so expensive yeah gigi and bella hadid
chevy chase's maternal grandfather was
cornelius vanderbilt crane another
vendor here to the crane company
he's cousins with anderson cooper his
father's second wife was a member of the
folger's coffee family
wild jesus do you know that carly
simon's father is simon of simon and
schuster i did know that i did not know
that eric
i didn't know that ariana grande's
father was rich yeah the ceo of some
design firm called
eb designs spike jones son of dude
spike jones who is so brilliant went to
my high school call me
uh this is not what phones look like
emily anymore
call me no it's like call me
we're miming for those of you not
watching um uh spike jones
is the son of arthur spiegel do you
remember spiegel catalog
no you're okay you were a newport news
bitch huh
you were delia's girl i spiegel
in roanoke virginia spiegel was
everything and it was a catalog that
it was like it was like amazon but like
a catalog stella mccartney of course
is the daughter of paul mccartney it's
like the purses are beautiful but like i
feel like a lot of people could have
thought of those purse designs
that just didn't have the you know the
beetle money so
so here's what i'll say like that
argument i can't i can't hear that shit
anymore okay so that's out
the tweets i know the tweets are here's
everyone's promise
first of all most tweets suck yep most
of your tweet everyone's tweets kind of
sucks
i'm concerned there's like a couple
people that consistently put out
like the people that are like whose
tweets suck i go to their page and it's
just like
i guess i'm gonna have an auto avocado
sandwich again
smh shake my head like who are you to
throw
stones at this like genius who of course
he sucks at tweets like you know what
where would he
he you're basically attacking him for
not being funny
right and that he never claimed to be he
never claimed to be funny and it's also
like yeah he builds spaceships and he
makes electric cars and he's like you
know trying to convert shit to
clean energy whatever right and but he's
not but he's not funny
this is the exact logic that keeps women
single for
so long oh my god they find a great man
and they're like yeah but like his
ankles are a little
short do you know what i mean yeah
i once was with this friend of mine who
was with this amazing guy we were
sitting next to each other at a wedding
and i'm like he said mate i talked to
him for like two hours i was like this
guy's great she's like
he has small wrists oh christ and i was
like dude
you got like where is this emotional
perfectionism where we expect everybody
to be
more perfect than we could like he's
basically he gave us a spaceship what
else do we want from him
so look yes is he a dick i'm sure he is
a dick like i'm sure
he's an arrogant punk like but anyone
who's like doing these kind of
jobs like i feel like we're just like
designed to like
hate them like i feel like when when
benjamin franklin was like
making electricity everyone was like ah
you know that guy who fucking
illuminated our homes that guy in his
kite yeah it totally looks like his dumb
fucking kite he was rude to my friend
once when he was holding his car
he wouldn't let my friend hold his coat
like when he was doing his experience
like what are you like
we just have these impossible exercises
you're jealous but anybody who is going
to be
like thinking like that that prolific
they are not good with people they can't
be
oh that's true like when people like
steve jobs wouldn't fucking say how did
yeah he didn't have time
yeah you know and my thing is like i
these people probably shouldn't even be
public figures as my guests that's the
thing we've crossed over but we know
that they're malignant narcissists of
course they're going to be and they need
to know that he needs to know the future
of everything he needs to have his hands
in bitcoin and this right
and a lot of these people are dorks that
just wanted to get fame and girls and
this is the only way they can do it
yeah and now they're still the same
person they were in high school and now
they're getting all the attention they
never got
right why are we excited if we stopped
bullying them and yeah in freaking high
school maybe this wouldn't
have but then we wouldn't have their
inventions that's true i just like steve
jobs i
i'm i'm kind of obsessed with him and i
know the whole thing zooms into
accusations
all right you want to go back to just
walking around a town holding a piece of
paper
trying to figure out where you are like
okay
do you use his inventions or not like do
you want to go
what are you okay steve jobs was a dick
okay it was
whatever his personality was to me is a
small price to pay
for being able to take a photo of
ourselves instantly and then
take out the crow's feet love that guy
love god blessings what are we doing he
was like very rude
you guys know that he was just like rude
to his employees yeah
he's not rude to their employees you
know he's fucking rude all of you guys
standing in the fucking apple line
waiting for the iphone
i've been waiting y'all are rude trying
to get his amazing inventions that's how
good they are
that's a very good take i don't think
that you can have that kind of mind that
goes
i'm gonna make something that everyone
won't be able to live without
the type of mind that has to think that
way is not the type of person who's like
hey how was your weekend
how's the family he's just like he's
trying to get eight
billion people addicted to a product
that's gonna change the world
like there's just a little bit of tunnel
vision yeah you guys gotta tell the
difference between being a bitch or an
asshole and just having tunnel vision
that is a very good job
what i'm saying they're different
whatever you're projecting this is what
it is the main thing is
look at what's going on with you that
you're projecting because when we don't
like people it's such a great
opportunity to find out what's going on
with
us and i see this addiction um
uh to hating people and i look at
everyone's issues with all of them and
i'm like oh that's you that's you
because
they become a rorschach test elon musk
is not going away in fact he's getting
more and more famous
because people won't stop tweeting about
how much they hate him right which is
what makes them big
you know what i mean so i just i i'm
fascinated by what's going on
why he triggers us so deeply i know
about the bolivia thing
he's really reckless on twitter but you
know
he's also reckless in the way that he
invents things and that's part of
um being good at what you do is you have
to take giant risks and you can't
self-edit because nothing would ever get
done i would never be able to write a
good joke if i was like okay i'm gonna
write a joke
you know about sexual assault i can't go
that's too risky
you have to go really fucking hard right
and then
those are the people that end up you
know he was like let's do a thing
i mean paypal he was like let's do a
thing where everyone puts their money
in the invisible internet right and then
trusts each other to send it to each
other
through the air right most people go
that does not sound good
right like you know so it's like people
that are reckless are usually
good at moving the ball down the field
even if they suck at twitter
you're like do you work in pr for billy
i don't i don't i
dude i have a hot take i like this take
because i really didn't agree with you
but i'm
i'm agreeing with all of that and you
don't have to agree with me i just i
just think that what we try to do on
this podcast is just a thought
experiment of like
or not do you know what i'm saying
because we're so addicted to hate i feel
like
hating people and judging i feel like
there are a couple people we can just
take off
of our plate so many people
just stick with stick with your dad and
your mom and your sister
you know there's elon musk doesn't need
to take up any of your psychological
energy or bandwidth
that's so you know what i mean just to
me look i i don't even like paypal i
think i
don't either when i'm on etsy um uh and
i go on to buy something i really want
it says like check out via paypal i'm
like oh yeah and then i just don't go
because i don't have it or whatever
right but um i just think we have to
remember that that moving forward with
like comedians thinkers inventors
whoever
like if you don't like someone it
doesn't mean they don't have a good idea
right you know i'm saying yeah what are
you gonna do boycott you're in a boycott
steve jobs
yeah what are you doing what are you
gonna get everyone's on their iphone
tweeting
i hate steve jobs it's like okay well he
won everyone's like
so he was on snl that's why i bring this
up a lot elon was
right and uh i don't know i just feel
like
why is everyone so surprised about that
like snl's always chasing people that'll
just either make them relevant or
that it seems like they're friends with
i can't say anything bad about it oh
that's right emily used to work at snl
sorry she just like fucking
disappears into the floor i just
understand wanted such a surprise like i
thought i didn't think he was that bad
i feel like his monologue like people
think it was awkward like that smells
awkward a lot
you know like i thought it was i don't
know i thought it was really refreshing
and kind of
cute and what the internet for
is not seeing the myst the like it's
repeating the same mistake of let's talk
about how much we hate someone
give them all the free people listening
in the world it did really well that
episode everyone watched it yeah and
even the people that didn't like llamas
are like i kind of like that guy now so
it was a smart move
your hate drove everyone to find him
charming and also
you want to make fun of someone from
africa with asperger's
[Music]
be a bully be emily's guest
go for it i mean he's i mean i feel like
wherever he was living in africa was
probably
it doesn't change doesn't change it is a
it is a
solid a solid point what if i told you
twitter was ablaze yesterday with making
fun of someone from africa with
asperger's what would you say
i'd go this is an outrage guess what
by the way i wouldn't say asperger's i
would say who's neurodivergent
because i'm not you're a boomer like you
jeff bezos he's an asshole that's the
other thing of course he's an asshole
what are you
saying he's such an asshole but right
now if i told you that jeff bezos
um you know is horrible to his workers i
think that i
i i've seen i've heard about the payment
stuff i don't know i'm not an expert
um whatever he's an asshole and he
cheats on his wife
would you stop using amazon
i'd find a way to rationalize it i'd be
like those child laborers need something
to do
we took them out of school i'm just
going to order some like school supplies
because
pack up my squad they can see what they
deserve
they can add the boxes while they're
going down the conveyor belt i just mean
like okay great he's an asshole now what
like
are you still going to stop ordering
your monster energy drinks one at a time
in a giant box
probably not who's the real asshole the
person that keeps buying one toothbrush
at a time
one eyeliner one two packaging nine
different boxes or is it jeff bezos the
guy that came up with the fucking idea
and that's the other that's the thing
that really annoys us about people like
that jeff bezos it's like
oh let's just like you know uh deliver
things it's such a
i could have thought of that anyone
could have thought of it but it would
take a
psycho or to execute it do it yeah
you're jealous
so when people are like oh that's a new
idea fuck him it's like okay
well congratulations you're not a psycho
did you do it they're psychos yeah
and they paid off for them yeah and they
don't even really seem that happy either
so we have to let our like super villain
billionaire people just be craving and
do their thing right
they actually benefit often and one of
them might be batman
and they they do abuse like yes if
there's workers rights issues
fix it oh and they might be batman
thank you i was so um uh
spiraling about uh trying to not be like
i'm pro-corporations
but i mean like screw the little man
yeah this is why i mean the guy that
invented antibiotics my guess is he was
a pretty big asshole
had to cut into a bunch of people and
fucking keep trying it out how it
happened
you know i don't know how but you know
what i'm saying oh yeah
the person who was like yeah let's put
like 300 people in a tube
and have them go through the sky that
was a crazy person
that was it who was like fuck you this
is a good idea use a fucking good idea
listen to me you asshole and then
now we have danes yeah i just don't
think you can get a good idea through
if if you're not an asshole that's a
really good point
i'm saying yeah i can't and all crazy i
really crazy ideas most people are gonna
be like i don't think that's gonna work
right you have to fucking you have to be
crazy and you have stock in the company
so all these people like steve jobs was
an asshole i'm like
i'd happily get yelled in the face by
steve jobs knowing i had stocking up
like go crazy bud go for it yeah no i
those are
i like that it's a hot take and that's a
hot take it's a hot take it's been a
pleasure podcasting um this will be my
last episode
100 we just defended rich white men
read the room everybody okay
fucking elizabeth holmes had that worked
we would hate her too then we started
hating billionaire women and then
equality would happen
everyone says i look like her and i
don't like it okay well it's amazing how
everything just goes back to you emily
elizabeth holmes she was the fact that
she got so rigged over the coals is
really is fascinating to me because i
feel like had it
worked we probably would have hated her
even more if we were taking our blood
tests
yeah yeah this was us just being like uh
ha ha like she made a little like
easy bake oven like faking you know this
is the one that made the blood
that was trying to do a little bit and
it like wasn't even real
she never even had one i mean so much of
this shit though they're like oh my god
she peddled something that wasn't real
and sold it to everybody like
you mean cellulite cream
you mean teeth whitening toothpaste
collagen water
yeah at least hers was like
all of these are things i've had to buy
a visionary
you're all things that i'm out of you're
shitting up on amazon
all right love you guys i'm sure we'll
hear from you yeah yeah
i'm no i'm indie i'm not a part of any
corporation we do this podcast in my
house
i'm the tyrant hr um bambi
i love you guys uh uh it is now time for
a conversation that is
not problematic with brandon k goodman
okay um brandon goodman you just
attacked me why
brandon kyle goodman i'm sorry brandon
oh brilliant
goodness so i do have my computer this
is the first time i'm allowing anyone to
see my computer it's on like a big
screen this is a huge mistake
um you're gonna see all the weird things
i googled
so many screens oh my you're about to
see my whole my emails okay look at the
number of etsy notifications
how dare you oh how dare you look at see
i'm sorry i've i ordered the other day
164 things on etsy in one day
wow look at this give me the top five
things you ordered top five things okay
they all have the same date you're not
oh wow this is recent
17 12 45. no this is a cry for help
um okay what's the last thing i got oh
uh shipping notifications this is
a mid-century modern pink loose site
um lucite uh fucking i used to call it
luchite
because i'm trash it's a it was like a
little thing that you put things in
so box so the problem is
don't try to put me in a box how dare
you i'm a white woman
you're right you're right you're right
you're you're diverse
look they used to they used to pay
productions to hire white women
very recently um it's a modern
mid-century
look here's the thing if you buy a bunch
of shit you need something to put it all
in so you buy a bunch of things and then
and then you buy things boxes to put the
things in yes i live for a box marie
condo really introduced me so like it's
endless needs look there's another box
zinc industrial box and basket
oh wow that's from france from front all
the way from from
what is this oh that is a little um
here's the only problem with ordering on
that see this is a cute little 1970s
colorblock vintage blur shirt i was very
excited to have it made me wear it on
the show today it came it was a
children's medium i was gonna say it
looks like a child
how about that looks like uh it does
look like a child's eye how about
this one on etsy ordered a bunch of
furniture for like that attic space that
you saw and i was like oh my god these
are like
hot deals like i cannot believe we spent
any money anywhere else this is so
inexpensive
uh gets here it's doll house furniture
i would be livid because i hate returns
i was like what am i going to do and
then now i have to have a doll house
yeah now i'm ordering
now we're going to buy it obviously i
don't want to waste money you always
want
to purchase so now i need to spend 500.
i'm not going to return it it's
too annoying so yes i am sorry you had
to just see the number of emails i have
hundred and three thousand or is that a
six i can't
unread that's unread so we're not
dealing with the fall
we're just dealing with the unread i
don't even know where you see that i'm i
thought oh there's my manager's email uh
at the bottom at the very bottom i
basically i emailed your manager and i
was like just make sure he's not funnier
than me today thank you
yes we're working on it and if if if
brandon is fighter than me we will cut
it
we'll cut all of his funny shit out all
the all the all the punch lines cut out
if um if uh he outshines me or steals my
thunder just
yes i sit and play you can just turn
these lights off yes i will also age him
um yes whatever i'm sorry you had to see
that i no
i i i too was once but never a hundred
a hundred thousand this is not a
judgment it's called boundaries
how are your boundaries doing you
responded to all your emails like a
psycho you're just giving your energy
out for just like
people i'm giving people access to me
i'm talking to them whenever they feel
like
half emails are circling back
if i didn't respond to you the first
time don't circle back
don't just move on to someone else one
of my agents emailed me
kindly following up which i loved i've
never got that before
kindly instead of kindly following up
how about make your first email more
appealing
okay which it was appealing because the
price that they the the fee was very
nice
okay but it's can i tell you it's
because you didn't respond at first and
they were like
the first answer is always no yes it's
always always no
absolutely i don't even have time for
this yes try again get it out get that
number one
yes and so i was with this woman this
weekend she was
the founder of female viagra oh yes
and then it was called female viagra
it's called addie i believe right cindy
eckert
okay and she only wears pink and she's
like a wild like business uh visionary
in that she just and i asked her i was
like how did you because they
offered to buy it for 200 million
dollars oh and she just
i would have been like absolutely
immediate i know
not paypal paypal me right now i accept
i
i accept i'd be like where do i go get
the gold bars
um i know nothing about right and then
she goes that's not she she said she was
like
channeling another person like we're
actors if you don't have self-esteem or
don't know what you're worth it's just
act like you do yeah and then
put the phone down and have a you know
nervous breakdown and go cry in your car
immediately
so she was like i don't know i just had
this like i was like it was like
channeled through me i was like that's
not enough they came back
with 800 million
and then she was in her office and she
just went she said she doesn't even know
where it came from she went
well that doesn't have a b in front of
it i was going to say
well 800. 800 like what are we doing oh
let's give me and if you were able to go
from two to eight
and i feel like there's a there's a bill
yeah and they she sold it for a billion
dollars
just because here's my old thing when
everyone's like every like actors and
artists that i know they're like
you know i'm anxious i don't you know
i've been scared then just act
like you are yes at work then go home
and then
you can spin out yeah oh my goodness no
why else
i would love to just see one billion in
my paypal account
[Laughter]
i would buy paypal and shut it down
because that shit is confusing i don't
like it
it's it's not user friendly where's just
when you go to
etsy and you're so set on buying
something and it's like okay pay by
paypal and you're like
ah yes but if paypal wants me to endorse
then
then it works beautifully okay i knew
this was gonna happen i was gonna go off
the rails
i'm self-conscious am i ashy uh if you
are i don't
put lotion on this is what i use this is
this is
um uh donna rawlings uh who's honor
donna rawlings is a friend of mine who's
a comedian who's started a cream
it's called raw just for action yeah
that's good and um he gave it to me and
i'm not
i'm i don't know if i'm even allowed to
use it but i use it on
my lips and elbows and legs and it's my
favorite thing on the planet
and it feels good it goes in yeah it's
an endorsement so no it's a good one
yeah
just wait hold don't don't say it the
name unless he hits your paypal
yeah okay don't fail my thing i do
nothing for free i used to be like yes
this is my favorite face screen that's
my favorite this is my favorite this is
like
i just want to share yes everything i
know and now i'm just like and then they
send you
the products but they don't send you the
check no that's not a fair see i could
have bought those forty dollar creams
myself
i now know the value of my engagement
yes
absolutely i mean i broke my off my
engagement i met the one that matters
um a social engagement social engagement
how are we friends
yeah i always start the podcast for like
a year now
i just hate it when people go on
podcasts and then they're sitting there
and then someone's like they're in this
and this and this and they did this
they're so interesting how about let
them talk yeah
we met do you know when we met i do okay
actually i don't know if you remember
when we met we met because i auditioned
for your pilot
at hbo and then i got called in the next
day for a call back and you were there
and it was like this
tiny hot little room yeah by the grove
yes by the grove
i remember the first time i was there i
could not find it because i was like
this is the grove
uh and then this is beneath me frankly
what am i doing
what is this beautiful office is this
for quibby
r.i.p um and that was first time we met
and then you didn't cast me which is
totally fine and you know
it's okay you know i don't have any hard
feelings about if we know anything about
when he comes we know that she's made a
lot of mistakes
but you did cast my friend gentile at
quite a lot yes i'm obsessed with you
yes she's a genius yes and that was like
i mean that was like really at a time
and i'm i really hope that because
you're gonna have so many tv shows and
be so famous that like
to just trust your gut like i did like
because when you have a bunch of
powerful producers right you don't
realize that you don't need them
they need you they need your fresh
instincts they need your fresh
the person that was gonna um play my
boyfriend
was gonna be i wanted a one andrew
schultz who has now become
huge but i was like oh he looks too
young for me and they're like i don't
know he looks too young they wanted
someone british for some reason
i did get to cast chrissy schula
in that pilot so
she was in i found her online okay
her videos were funnier than anything i
saw on television she did that uh the
i'm hot video
the um jesus me raindrop um oh
yes oh she's so brilliant oh that video
oh oh
hi that video okay many a cackle these
are like pretty
yeah this is when like yeah this is
pretty tick-tock this is
yeah no she was like doing some shit she
was working in customer service at a
bank i want to say
oh also have you seen her talk about
lana del rey no okay i i'm so sorry we
will i have to show it to you please
it's one of the funniest things i've
ever seen and imagine she has a hot take
on it
oh yes in this video this one it got six
million views
i think she says i um
let's not silence a black woman no by
accident um
and she was just and i saw every actress
on the planet and it was just sort of
like
you know
i am sitting hold on it is 91
000 damn degrees
i am sitting right next to my air
conditioner look at this timing
right right next to it it is on the
lowest temperature
on the highest damn speed okay
64 degrees and it's on turbo
what the fuck do i need to put this
bitch on power rangers i mean
this is firing door how okay he need to
heat the houses of the people
that is not what hold on bring the devil
from hell
and halfway when you pray i ask the lord
to make it warm
i did not say lord please
bring the devil from hell and have him
sit his ass crack on earth
that's not what i asked for that is not
what i requested
okay he need to heat the houses or the
people who was begging for summer
all damn winter and fall all the
motherfuckers that was making pictures
and special little telegrams and
counting down the days to someone i
can't wait to be on the beach
i can't wait to enjoy myself and be in
the sun when you put the sun
in their fucking living rooms and you
make my damn living room she's
yelling at god i mean she's arguing with
god the lord
yeah do this i can't do this what's that
book the door guys
delegate temperature like this the lord
need to
delegate temperature and weather to
somebody else where the hell is moses
to talk to moses okay so i was just like
i need this
like i have to have this and i want her
and it'll be like take this
and you can write whatever you want like
improvise whatever
she had never auditioned for a show
before i mean she
shows up at hbo to the test
and you know a test is like there's
three people like you're terrified your
life is about to change
i just get this job i'm gonna be able to
fucking pay my rent you know and she
shows up
well she didn't audition with us first
and she showed up with three shirts and
was like what shirt do you want me to
wear and it was just like
it was just so like so
and she's so innocent killed yes killed
it
love it got the job and you do this in
your work i'm obsessed with bravery
um i'm obsessed with bravery risk taking
and i think so many great artists have
had to compromise their vision and not
take risks
to be either amenable or sanitized or
whatever that is
that is not what you do um let me just
show you the beginning of this
this was shot on martin luther know
right okay
can we turn this up a tiny bit more
sorry i just want to be as loud this is
watching years ago oh my god
it's still to me funnier than half the
stuff on television she's hilarious
no no but the the the she's just like
no one's gonna talk she's all about the
elephant in the living room yes
talk about it okay happy birthday dr
king
something is wrong with lana del rey's
face and we need to talk about it
because it has not been addressed but
folks have been questioning nicki
minaj's ass
and the validity validity of it for
years and i
do not appreciate that okay
her face is wrong it is wrong
i say often that the lord don't make
mistakes
but her face is a math equation that he
has
yet to solve you're not about to tell
me that your jaw is perpendicular your
mouth is parallel and we gonna be
all right no but now that's not what
you're gonna tell me
is your nerve talk about i didn't have
any work done i don't know what people
are talking about
bitch there is a fiddler on the roof
of your top lip and it's lopsided in one
legged oh my god
a level of savage rooted in a
a a deep knowledge of broadway
absolutely and we respected our
ancestors at the beginning happy
birthday doctor it was it was
dr king's birthday let me just and then
the the pause of
i mean she truly chose chaos and
violence
but just so like oh my god someone
that's not scared and i just feel like
there's just so much fear
and is do you feel like the internet is
kind of the place right now to be able
to
to to like do what the fuck you want to
do i think so i think we were talking
about like tick tock earlier and i just
don't have energy to figure out how to
make it but it's always so inspiring
to go through those videos and see what
people come up with and how they create
and it's because
there are no boundaries right like you
don't have a network saying that's not
funny but uh yeah
and i think that the industry's trying
to catch up because so many of these
social media creators are creating
things that are working right that are
hitting
that we were told wouldn't hit well like
you see you know i think tabitha brown
is an
incredible example because of how much
she has permeated
the zeitgeist and she also talks about
so
beautifully like how she didn't think
her voice was
she thought her voice would hinder her
her hair would hinder her all these
things and it's like she is
one of the biggest social media stars
right now and it just shows
that like there is an audience it's also
like hey all you gay keepers just get
out of the way get the fuck out the way
so i think there's been a while where
we've been like oh god social media is
so annoying i'm not getting paid i'm not
getting this but it's also like
you know and also i think we're learning
that it used to be when you finally got
a job in a network uh
or corporate situation the amount of
money you were making like you didn't
realize that
that that your writer fee and your
talent fee you had to pay
all these publicists yeah all these like
office spaces all this crazy stuff and
then you got the tiniest bit and now the
advertisers are coming right to us it's
like
you guys have so much money there's so
much money i just did we didn't you were
paying like
50 people and i got the scraps yes a
thousand percent and now it's like
it gives the creator the power and also
i think
it calls into question like what is good
right like
you know they're like who gets to decide
what's good the audience
should decide not fucking five white
dudes in a room because the audience
doesn't get to see all the great pilots
or the great shows that were
that were passed on because they showed
it to a focus group in las vegas of all
white people
right by the way focus groups are
literally meth heads not even joking
so i've done i used to do focus groups
before i was in tv
i would do the like neutral gene like
you get on a list where you do product
testing and you get 50
cash so that's how i made money i would
also sell um
guys i was dating his clothes at buffalo
exchange um
good old buffalo it's like mine you
cheat on me it's fine just give me that
give me that polo remember
that vintage beetle shirt um and uh
and when you go into focus groups like
there is some value in it as someone
like live performers that we know that
instant reaction from an audience yes
but this is a very flawed system because
they essentially pick up a pilot or not
based on a bunch of people in arizona
where are we signed up for a focus
group test who needed fifty dollars real
quick yes they success sure so when i
used to go do like neutrogen i remember
i would do the um
neutrogena had like a scrub and we'd use
it for a week and we come in and talk
about our experience and i was such a
nerd that i'd like you know i feel like
the packaging and all the methods were
like
like we need to go get drugs before we
go into dts
so it's like also like these random
straight we're in the power of like we
don't know what that
diversity looks like and those girls we
don't know what the age is like like how
it and also
beholden to i think people wanting to
repeat things and copy things right
there's such a
uh it's like if if i remember when this
is us
was really popular i think there were so
many versions of that that then came out
which like let's do more shows with one
black guy
yeah and you're like okay that's this is
us works but like we don't have to do
that 15 times over on every network like
where's the originality and i think that
that's
what social media is providing is a
space where there's so much and look at
how many followers i got off of being
original this is more than most of your
tv shows
yes you know it's annoying we have to
prove our value but i think it's like a
better way than going into one audition
where you could have had a bad day or
the script sucks and it's like
but um i love that you said that because
i think so many
um people in our business tend to list
this podcast um for some reason probably
because they're trying to go like am i
getting canceled this week
um and i remember when bridesmaids came
out uh-huh
yes after it's like huge huge success i
started getting all these calls i'm sure
many other writers did
um going uh hey can you do the next
bridesmaid yes
like four women on a camping trip drunk
and crazy for women
like you know on like an office retreat
crazy and i remember just being like
no no no honey you don't we can't that
was done
it's done the reason it was great it was
because it was an original idea don't
replicate the idea replicate
the instinct behind the idea which was
to do something risky and original yes
which was to give a performer like
kristen wiig the reigns to do
what she wanted to do and i think it's
it i don't think
any sort of like uh copycat version ever
works
which is wild that we keep doing that's
insanity right we keep doing the same
thing over
and over expecting a different result
and then what they do is they redo it
with a bunch of funny women uh another
version of it and it bombs
and they go oh see it was a fluke see
that didn't do well
women aren't funny that was just a flu
because it came out on fourth of july
and there wasn't another movie against
it or whatever
which i think also sucks is the pressure
that you know i think is on a queer
person
on women on black folks on indigenous
folks is that like
if your thing flops there's now
the industry goes well see we'll never
do that again yeah well we did it with
all your shitty white showrunners you
paired us with right
exactly we never there was no i think
that's the other thing that's shifting
now and i hope which is that
you get these shows that are uh have
representation
but the creative team around it is does
not represent people on the show
so it doesn't work and it's like will
you please just let
us do what the fuck we want let me know
who i want to hire
let me write the thing i want to write
let me make it a specific and it's weird
and as awkward and as funny as possible
yeah
and i promise it'll go and also by the
way you'll make more money
yes you'll make so much more money so
much more and then also i don't want you
to
feel like this podcast you have to like
talk about these seriousness the whole
time if you do or you don't it's totally
up to you absolutely but you're allowed
to go like let's just talk about
something dumb
i have games i can do it all you're
going to put crystals on my face and
decorate my face
and i'm also realizing that we are
really like not just hollywood but real
friends because
he did show up and i last minute put
extensions in my hair that live in this
amazon box come through
and i just put them in really quickly
and they're all just showing and you
have said nothing
no i noticed that you didn't notice that
i'm trying to
look i only saw you from the front and i
was like oh your hair looks great when i
walked in this is what i saw this is the
vision i had and i was like oh
cause you gave up on me being sane a
while ago
i give up on any fucking person in
hollywood being saying none of us are
i feel like i i like i don't know if i
just cuz because
we did work together at a time when i
was half in co
covet fog yes i do remember there was a
time where i had such bad gastritis
after covet that we were like
zooming about something and i had to get
up and puke and i came back yes you did
and you were like me and tyler were like
are you okay
you're like no my mother looks like okay
so i was like you're like i just puked i
was like
okay so like should we end the zoo it
was wild
i mean so we're working on a project
together which i do want to discuss at
some point
because i very much feel like oh
in five years someone's gonna do it and
we're gonna be like we just did there
yeah you know and like like the comeback
is one of my favorite shows ever uh yes
melissa and still it's ahead of its time
still
yes if you watch it now when it came out
it was so ahead of its time and it made
people cringe and uncomfortable
and they just didn't know what to do
with it because no one cared about an
older woman's experience at the time
right and that's what it was about
like and then it was about like if a
woman is in a tv show or movie without
makeup all the critics call her brave
yeah you know stuff like all these
little things like lisa cooter in
general i feel like deserves
everything under the sun and life is
also like
far ahead of and i got to do a pilot
with her
i'm in the pilot business now oh yeah i
got to do a pilot that's where money is
at amazon about this and lisa kudrow was
running
a basically the ombudsman's office the
hr department
at a college okay and she like didn't
know the right terms and she's trying to
catch up
and she's like well and the name of the
football team is the chiefs
and she has to like change it you know
it was or it was
it was uh maybe it was the indians and
she was like well it used to be cowboys
and indians
and now we gotta like all of and
revealing all of the like
economic obstacles to changing these
team names
of like yeah but we're not going to get
our donors all of our alumni have their
you know
whatever their their chiefs tattoo like
how it's so
insidiously um uh frustrating to just
make a change that should be so obvious
yes should be changed
yeah and then she was kind of like
trying to figure out like
like wait is it gender non-conforming is
it gender non-binary like she's like
she's just like behind and doesn't know
who to ask because she's too afraid to
get fired sure
you know so it's just like and then she
can't google it because then it'll know
her the computer will know it
and then she's got an alexa and she
unplugs all her devices before she asks
somebody anything
josie total played um
of the office who would like give her
all the like you can't say that you
can't do that yeah yeah
no but don't but don't wear that either
like it was just like
it was so fun but we got to do this
pilot together um that i'm
you know everything everyone's like do
something really edgy and then
as soon as you make it the place you
were making for is owned by disney
and you're like wait okay okay yeah okay
why did you hire me like the way these
like
i almost seem like at the point where
i'm like let's just freaking raise money
and shoot this ourselves on our phones
and like yes let's monetize this
friendship
no hangs that are not monetized
you know because it's just so so i'm so
glad i got to go through that process
with you
but it was no one was ready for that it
was exciting to
uh i haven't built a pilot from you know
i i joined you guys kind of midway
through but just kind of going through
the process of
pitching it and by the way we wrote it
with you and mine without telling you so
taylor tomlinson and i were writing this
pilot
for brandon k goodman and we were like
we wrote the whole thing and we're like
on your instagram or like he would say
this
and then we're like we we didn't ask him
if he wants to be a part
because we're fully writing this for him
yes and you were like i have this pro
i like i want to talk to you about being
on this thing and i thought you were
talking about
this i was like oh my goodness i would
love to be a guest on good for you but
then it was like this pilot which is
a bigger deal are you like oh my god no
i just wanted to build my following
oh my goodness no but it was it was a
you you and taylor are so
fucking funny and so it was exciting to
just like see comedy brains i mean i'm
in big mouth too
but i don't consider myself a stand-up
so i'm always like fascinated by
stand-up brains i'm not a stand-up i'm
just a comedian but yeah you're not
mentally ill i get it
i'm bragging we get it you're stable
um i go to therapy don't worry about it
um so it was just like cool
like watch your brains work and that was
exciting and to get to like
know what that's like it was such a
great experience because
you know i feel like i'm finally at the
point in my life where i can like
take disagreement more creative
not even conflict creative differences
and not take anything personally
or not assume the other person like not
um patronize the other person because a
lot of times we're like oh i can't say
this this person will hurt their
feelings that's insulting to them
yeah that's insult you're saying you're
not an adult you can't handle it no one
gives a shit
so it was like so exciting to get in
there and write these like really
um scenes that were really like for lack
of a better word like tricky
yeah yeah and be able to be wrong
and go okay well this character would
have to be wrong and this would
what like and then i mean we're having
conversations like what's like a racist
thing someone would say it's not too
racist
but just on the line of braces and then
if you told me i'd be like yeah but
that's not racist enough
like i just need to make sure
what's so interesting as a creator is i
think that uh white people
are very sensitive so like as a black
person i'm like yes it would be this and
you're like that
are you sure it'd be that much that far
or
it's like yeah because then you're like
i've never seen someone do that but that
doesn't mean it doesn't happen
yes yes i would never do that but it's
like it happens all the time all the
time and trying to find
sort of the new because you know on i
may destroy you
you know she did the thing where someone
like went for her hair
you know and also making sure it's not
something that's been done yes so it's
like going in these tricky territories
like we're trying to like illuminate and
shed light on and i'm like
yeah no no no not that one i'm just like
saying no to your
i think we can go deeper than that how
do you with your work balance
like not re-traumatizing yourself or not
spending all your bandwidth
on this but also putting all your heart
into your work
i set really clear boundaries which is
really uh
something that's arose uh arisen has
come up in the last
year yeah uh because i'm somebody i'm a
i think i'm a recovering perfectionist
and people pleaser and so i love to say
yes to everything
and also in this industry when you get
no's for like a like a decade when you
start getting yeses you're like yes to
everything but
yes but wait oh it's after scale it's
four hundred dollars in marina del rey
um so uh so it's just a matter of being
able to say no and being able to say oh
i'm done at this time
and started to do that where it was like
i have to be finished with work
six or seven it's because as a as a
white woman
who gets whatever i want whenever i want
if he's like i have two from two to four
and then we start and
like it's 350 and i'm like okay so let's
just i i mean
he's like well i'm getting off the phone
i'll see you guys i'm leaving you ten
off the minutes yes and then taylor and
i all co-dependent we're working for
five more hours you're like what would
brandon say oh we should have asked that
when he was on the call
you're training people to respect your
time as well and you're helping other
people when you do that
because then they realize they can do it
too i you know i think it's uh you know
you have to treat yourself the way you
want to be treated and so for me it's
like this is my time but it's more than
that it is
should you say like uh what people want
from me right now are conversations
about race and gender and sexuality
which is fine that's my experience i'm
happy to share that but
it also comes at a cost and at a certain
point i'm like i would like to watch
real housewives now because then also
it's like oh you want to um uh you know
but coming i don't want to be like
dramatic or like embarrass you but
coming like very much
in my opinion which means nothing like
the go to
what how i should process this
information i'm seeing in the news so
how i cannot burden my friends of color
with like
how do you feel about that or like what
i just i always just say go to brandon's
page you go to brandon
and also you when people come to you and
they're probably so what are you it's
like just go to my page
it's all there yes it's really it's
really going away sometimes i get these
vms and i'm like
sometimes people send me these like long
dm's and i and god bless y'all but i do
not read them because i'm like if it's
not a dick pic
absolutely
just questions about your trauma no
thank you i think i was talking to gabby
uh said about this about um something
called an asshole
it's someone who asks you a question
that they could easily get the answer
from google or something else yes and
you're just like what are you
like and i don't i don't know what that
psychology is but i think we all do it i
think we all
want human connection and wanna you know
connect in some way so we might think
it's easier to like ask the person or we
think we're making them like feel
special like
i want to learn it's like yeah but don't
you're not paying me by the hour right
now
you're not and it's and and we neglect
the fact that that person it now has to
unpack something for you yeah and they
don't necessarily want to do that or at
the time because i'm gonna answer it and
then you're gonna have another question
and then i'm gonna answer that question
and there's gonna be another question
because i'm interesting and you know
nothing about this
and there are so many youtube videos
already so it's been so
hard like my life is so hard i know um
it's just so hard for me but like how do
you go because i find a lot of people
and i'm on clubhouse a lot
um just try it's not for everyone i'm
really guarded about it i'm really just
about listening and sometimes i'll host
rooms and just ask questions
so that i understand i'll run ideas by
people like you know um
me and some friends that make movies
we'll get on there and ask people like
do you want to see this do you not want
to see this
um you know the overwhelming reaction to
a friend of mine who's a movie producer
was like no more black trauma movies
please please
uh a white man killing a black girl and
then the white actor wins the oscar
we're
good totally stuff like that we were
like i can't ask friends that but this
is like a place where we're sharing it
yeah where am i going oh when as someone
that like a lot of people think is like
a woman in business who's like an
entrepreneur like successful at a time
when there were it was only men or
whatever and people asked me to be on
these panels
like will you do this panel where you
talk about being a woman in business and
how to know your self-worth and i'm like
all right how much you paid me
and they're like oh no it's free and
it's like well i can't me going
i'd be being a hypocrite and setting
about example yes so because i'm a woman
in business
yeah i want to so anyone that talks on
that panel sucks a business
unless you're unless you're paying in
some way yes you know so giving away
your time for free is like number one
and that's number one yeah i for now we
i only do panels if it's connected to
an organization or a person that like i
am cool with yeah a friend or something
like that that but yeah just like a
random
kind of like or like i'll get we will
get asked so often for me to like give
like speeches but like there's no fee
and i'm like so you want me
to speak for 20 minutes
for free it's like people like what do
you think because i can turn that into a
netflix special
and make a lot of money literally but
god bless you for
i think that's the big thing right now
is like god bless you for asking
you don't get points for thinking i'm
great because i'm great
like that's the mentality you don't get
points for that yeah but if you think
i'm so great why are you stealing my
time
we now take a this is actually very
weird because brandon goodman
whom you are currently listening was
that right the way it was said of whom
don't correct me
um
you're not allowed to just shoot me with
the nerf gun that
says the person without the nerf gun
[Laughter]
i made a huge mistake dyeing your hair
pink
you have too much confidence i'm a new
woman go back please go back to blonde
where you were
constantly full of shame and apologizing
for everything never i'm so obsessed
with betterhelp even before
they worked with us on the podcast
brandon goodman and i and taylor one
taylor tomlinson
wrote a script which we're talking about
in this podcast where
all of their problems were solved by a
better help therapist at the end because
they realized that they were just
recreating their childhood circumstances
and doing like
uh essentially acting like they're
mothers if that's not a ringing
endorsement we don't even need this
i'm actually gonna find the script hold
on write about read about it and i'll
show you what we wrote about it this is
so
i just remember so serendipitous yeah
betterhelp will help you
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online and it's available
to clients
worldwide even in the tv world okay look
so i'm pulling this up
you're playing mara i'm i'm beatrix okay
okay
you know what i think i need to talk to
someone a professional like a therapist
or something therapists are so lazy they
just tell everyone to go to aaa so they
don't have to do your job the characters
now call it
no they don't that's a you thing white
women and this is brandon's character
do white women talk about anything
besides therapy i mean i can't afford to
go to one right now
wait they have online therapy now wait
butterhub.com
promo code my favorite murderer that's
really in a script
that is so exciting we should do my
promo good for you
i know i have such low self-esteem that
i didn't even put my podcast in there
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and good for you listeners get 10
off their first month for at
betterhelp.com whitney
that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash which name and hulu i bet
you're just just
losing sleep over not picking that up
after our reading of the pilot
i hope a casting director is watching i
want to get out of here i got pink hair
i'm going to be in the picture
betterhelp.com i need it now we've been
talking this podcast with brandon
goodman about self-care
about putting herself first about
boundaries let's walk the walk
and talk about how we feed ourselves
daily harvest which we've talked about a
lot
i'm not even joking i'm not going to sit
down and cook a meal
and i don't i don't have time no i'm an
adult woman with needs yeah
as a single person i know i'm single
it's really hard
to buy groceries for yourself do you
know anything like it's depressing i
i don't want to buy four chicken breasts
in like six pounds
two bananas right so one for sex one to
eat
okay that's a messy uh so that's why
you don't you
[Laughter]
you're right it is it is it's depressing
it's depressing and i love daily harvest
because you can buy those i love the
cheddar broccoli cheese bowl it's like a
single
person it's great for single people yeah
stay don't find
your soul mate because then you won't be
able to have daily harvest the same way
and they also make their almond milk my
lk so you can buy that with
that comes in the delivery and bam
you're done those are your ingredients
everything you're done walk out the door
it's a dream get started to get
get started today go to dailyharvest.com
and enter promo code
good for you to get 20 get get started
today
go to dailyharvest.com and enter promo
code good for you to get 25
off your first box i did that joke first
that's promo code good for you for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
that's dailyharvest.com yum why are
there no bullets in it i won't teach her
how to do shit
you don't know how to you don't know how
to cock it oh i know how to go
with a banana i think you know and it's
interesting like you know i'm
in the very new phase of people seeing
me or whatever that means
and it's like oh i guess you're like
i've gotten like famous like ig famous
yeah famous but it's just like it's
interesting when people see me and it's
like oh i want
you know what's really creepy for me is
and it started having
pre-coveted and now it's starting to
happen now that everyone is like able to
be in restaurants with their mask where
like i'll be with a friend
key keying talking to talk and then like
somebody
like 10 20 minutes later be like you're
and it's like oh my god how much you do
what did you just played a video about
lana del rey's face
for about 20 minutes yeah so what did
you hear what was it so like that
i imagine i'm sure that you experience
this all the time i'm sure it's like oh
right like
you again why the boundaries are
important because
you do belong or people feel like you
belong to them
and so there's not a respect for your
privacy and there's not a respect for
your
boundaries especially when you're out in
the world and so like having my own
like privacy boundaries has become
incredibly important and to be
to ask people to pay for my time that's
the only thing it feels i'm like i feel
bad like oh it's for this like college
like i should do a 20-minute talk but
it's like no like that
because then all the other colleges are
going to find out you work for free and
then you ask for money and they're going
to be like
yes we set a precedent and it's but i
think there's like that that uh the
guilt
of it feeling like it's all about the
money and it's not all about the money
but it is about respecting and this is
for anybody it's like it is about
respecting your own it's all about the
money for thomas jefferson why can't it
be all about the money amen absolutely
it could be all about that why are we
allowed to
want be greedy and want money like this
like you're so ambitious like you have
so much money it's like yeah if i don't
take it
someone else is going to take it like
what and i i can give it to p you know
what i mean
it's just sort of like i say that to my
asm all the time where it's like because
he
has uh we both have like we neither of
us grew up rich so we all have our
you know this we all have our like stuff
around what is yours i have a test
um well mine is more so like i have
never wanted to depend on anyone so even
if i got married which i am i was like i
knew like even my husband was
you know a billionaire hey bill gates
but no green i've been single right now
i will um even if that were the case i
always wanted to be able to take care of
myself and do for myself which comes
from
being raised in a single-parent
household like my mother was an
independent
uh woman and actress and
a black woman and it was that's what i
watched and so i i knew that that was
important to me
um and so now being in a partnership
that's interesting to navigate right
like
our expenses together and like what that
means but also like
is it okay to have money and for my
husband
he's always kind of been afraid of
having too much money and for me i'm
like
it's going somewhere and at least if it
goes
to our home like we can use it to
support other people
to like give back to whatever works or
go on the trip i deserve to go on our
finances
would finance my own independent movie
half of it so that i have more control
you know to hire other people to to make
other work whatever like it's like it's
going somewhere yeah and
we need it for the divorce lawyer
but i i i i just want to pause on this
because i think so many people go
through this and there's something so
fascinating to me about having sort of
like whether it's imposter syndrome or
having
money or having a problem solved and
being like well who am i without this
problem and this worry and this anxiety
yes that's another thing the way that we
glorify being punerious
and and not having money like there's
like we romanticize it a little bit and
the starving artist is a bit of a thing
that we romanticize so i'm a real
i'm a real artist because i'm starving
because i have no money it's like yeah
okay save it
donate it yeah or go buy real estate
invest in it
yeah in yourself you know as a black
person as a black queer person
you know i think that what we as a black
community are figuring out is like
generational wealth
yeah yeah i mean we're the america
fucked us right uh and so to be in this
generation
gently fucked us so
you know i think that's another reason
why that's important to me because i
want
to have my black children be raised with
money to experience what it is to have
access to any and everything they want
so it's not just like oh i want to like
have my cute little gucci bag i'll get
the gucci bag
but there's also like my mother busted
her ass to give me access to things
she worked her ass off so that i could
go to france on a trip so that i could
go to amsterdam so that i could
experience things that were outside of
her budget but she figured it out
and i want to make sure that i'm able to
do that with ease like she didn't want
you to um
uh read all the textbooks that had were
completely wrong
about how the native americans and the
pilgrims
got along great yeah all these stupid
fucking books or february where it's
like oh let's talk about martin luther
king
inherited to admit and that's it i don't
know we have to talk
so we have to later get into the all the
sort of like
stuff that we learned that is not at all
true at all like all inaccurate that's
about such a better education to just
let your kid go to france and like
figure out who they are you know what's
interesting too about the education part
what i said to somebody recently or
maybe in this last year i was like when
i saw hidden figures
what kind of opened my mind about that
was i didn't even know to
ask that question and that's what's
weird because you go through it's not
weird but
i mean that's kind of the beauty of the
system you go through
schooling and you're taught okay your
your history your black history
specifically is harriet tubman
maybe you'll hear about frederick
douglass martin luther king malcolm x
and like now we're cool
right but you never thought so think to
ask oh
like were there black women in nasa like
were there you know like where else
have we existed uh and if that's not
happening at home necessarily
then you never consider that never and
so there are all these people that i'm
learning about especially even black
queer people
uh learning about lady chablis or stormy
de la vie
and being like i didn't even know to to
ask about who these
these queer black folks were um or
because or even thought they existed
yeah you know
there's um uh and i know i've talked
about this a lot on the podcast
um uh i'm working on this project to
renovate
this hotel in west virginia i'll come
through called
uh uh you are hired uh with pay
for the opening number when we launch
i love it um and it's still sort of
figuring out the ownership i can't like
i can't reveal everyone that's sort of
involved yet
yeah um know that it's not just a white
woman
uh where on the john brown raid uh
occurred
is this place called hill uh harpers
ferry virginia my dad actually west
virginia my dad actually worked at this
hotel called hilltop house
which was built by a free slave um and
uh was burnt down
and then it was rebuilt and then burnt
down again and it's kind of fallen to
shit but there's a ton of black history
like literally if i just showed you the
videos there's just like yeah like boxes
and boxes of papers
and there's you know i i'm obviously not
educated enough about it but there's so
many um there were slave uprisings by
women yeah
that obviously they didn't live to tell
the story but there's this woman named
like pearl tatton and
we're coming across all this history
there's just like never been told about
this woman that
stood up at a slave auction yes
you know and of course no one's gonna
tell that story nobody cares that was
just like a
you know to punish somebody you know
george washington we were just talking
about this his teeth were not wooden
they were from slaves
he took that you know so there's just
all this stuff that's like you know
obviously it's like heartbreaking
but how what is a way to sort of like
like bring the stuff up without
re-traumatizing or putting all the work
on people of color to have to do it like
the lucas brothers were on last week and
they're like okay now that we did fred
hampton
um you know the the uh panther story now
i want to just go do something dumb
you know we don't want to have to only
tell stories about black people that
were killed
by the government yeah so it's like kind
of just like
you know it's on yeah so that's that but
i mean learning
so much so much i think the wild thing
is which is always wild to me is that
we are in an age where there is so much
access yeah and so the fact that people
are still going i don't know i don't
whatever is like well you're not being
curious
right like you have to have a level of
curiosity to be like
let me question what has been presented
to me let me like
if i'm uh i say this to every parent and
i don't have kids but this is what i
would
do is like look at their curriculum like
let's ask questions about what's on that
curriculum
and who are these authors and like if
you don't know there are like look them
up make sure there's somebody black and
queer make sure there's some women like
and then if if they're not then like
let's make a shift
like pivot excuse put your thinking cap
on thinking
as i used to say as they used to say
it's not that confusing
you know so to me it's like yeah like
just quite my dad used to say this and i
and i feel so grateful looking back
because he always would like to tell me
something like how do we know the book
is right like
this yes and i never and i was like oh
my god who did write this
and that person obviously you know okay
this person's you know
everyone's the hero that wrote the
version of what happened i'm like well
and he'd be like well the dead people
didn't get to give their side of the
story you know
that's real and then just anything if
you tell me something right now and then
i tell someone two days later i'm gonna
fuck up story a little bit
you know we're never taught to question
authority we're never taught to question
anything i think that's what needs to
shift is that we have to be curious be
willing to do
our research and and and be willing to
be wrong
and be willing to not know everything
that's other thing like be willing to be
wrong about some shit and be willing to
like feel like oh i don't
like as you said earlier like these
boxes that we found i'm not fully
educated on it but like
that's okay like you don't have to know
everything
don't talk about it if you don't know
about it yeah yeah right but also it's
like
there are things that are you know i i'm
trying to start
like because i think people want a lot
of credit for being like abraham lincoln
was actually racist
yes it's like okay let's just step back
and i think we can learn the mo
i have no skin in the game on abraham
lincoln but let's just figure out what
the circumstances
were and like he did the wrong thing but
why was he in a situation where both of
his choices were bad
like what like what did he do okay so
because i think a lot of people
cling on to this like when people were
mad at john wayne and i was like not
john wayne i was like what is your do
you don't know him
right what's your attachment like
abraham lincoln if he made if he fucked
up but
like he was a product of his time and
i'm sure did a lot of fucked up shit
like
like let's talk about why someone that
we've now
put someone on a pedestal yes why we
only chose to tell the good parts and
none of the bad parts like what's
like with hitler it's like uh uh
now's the time the show where we talk
about hitler okay
but i think it's just important to think
like because i always go okay now that
we've we all agree hitler is a
bad boy yes he's a naughty boy putting
it like that
um now go why did millions and millions
of people
believe what he was saying and and
execute or uh i'm sorry
well it is executed yeah but execute his
execution think about the psychology
let's ask the question
which which i think is so beautiful in
germany which is that they are teaching
the good the bad the ugly so that's that
your german accent no that's hot
no
[Laughter]
give me an snl immediately um no yeah i
i think that
they it's like what america is obviously
continues to do wrong is we're not
willing to say
let's look at these people and see the
good the bad and the ugly and like
figure out how to not repeat this
shit yeah we have no choice but to
forgive them at this point because we
forgive other people dead
they don't give a fuck like you know
what i'm saying like it's like does
lincoln care what his legacy is he's
dead he's dead he's gone he wore a wig
most of the time and uh
when you start going like like
everyone's like but these men were great
men and they
wore the constitution they had on a
weave on their face they
they were killed people were silly
gooses is what they were they don't give
a fuck
so old but we are alive and
whatever they did is still impacting us
yeah so
but they're gone but like what can we
learn just take emotions
out of it yes no one cares you know
what's hearing this conversation that
we're talking about you know so to me
it's like
and you look at hitler and you go okay
hitler's bad hitler's bad then people
get so emotional about it but it's like
why did all these people listen to him
he owned the media
they had no way to corroborate when he
said jews are why you're poor
when you're poor your iq goes down like
he knew exactly what he was doing so
let's learn how manipulation
works right and then figure out a way
when we see it here but we don't do that
because then we
we left why we literally had a trump for
four years right it's like and then it
went to stalin to sylvia berlusconi
like this happens everywhere continue to
repeat it because we refuse to
really dig into it like we can say
that's bad or that's good but also like
let's explore the psychology because we
have to go
why did everyone love him so much
instead of going he was an asshole
not to them right like 17 people say 6
million i think it's like 17 million
people died
in the holocaust because it was like um
you know it wasn't whatever
yeah yeah yeah click bait
whitney denies the holocaust and swears
it was more
and there i go um
[Laughter]
a little bright here so it's just like
when people are and i think that it's
important to remember like every human
being is wired
to be the most afraid of shame and the
fear of being wrong so when someone's
like actually this is what happened in
history and you're like okay when
your ego gets involved like take your
ego out of it why would you know the
truth yes like why would like just
you know to me it's like i'm i'd rather
just you know like when people are
you know stand behind a bad idea because
their ego gets in the way
yes and i'd rather be right than think
i'm right
and you know what the fucked up shit to
me is about it all
is that we are revealing so much
corruption happening in present
day right now and the only reason we're
being able to like reveal it
is because we have cameras we have
social we're like you know you're not
able to get away
but it's like okay if this much
corruption is happening right
now in 2021 then what was happening back
then
so how do you know again how do you know
that your history book is correct it's
not
and also yeah oh donate which honestly
that reference like social media is so
bad like okay everyone just calm down
social media is a miracle
you're letting the rotten eggs ruin it
like
for someone a civilian to be able to
film something and
upload it is the only way out of this
fucking mess absolutely so it's like
people
like just film it film it if you see
something bad stop like getting on my
page and telling me i look old like go
change the world you can go
change the world anything right now you
know so i know q anon's not ideal but
like
you know like there has to then the good
people just need to speak more so that
that becomes a smaller voice you know
yeah we have to remember you know the
it's a space for a lot of things to
happen but those of us who are
on the right side of things have to just
like band together
and be a community in the same way that
those really bad
things that are happening they are a
community yeah you cannot divide them
but for us there's a cracks in
us and we have to really seal those
cracks so that
and also when you start complaining
about the comments on your page and
stuff like that you don't be arrogant
like these are people that are not well
to me it's sort of like these people are
sick you know and i just send you love
and i just like
i just respond to them and i just go i
hope that helped
i hope you
that's the thing to me is like i i who
are you like you don't have access to me
anymore
you lost your privileges that's all but
to me i like
i just go like hey i hope that did for
you what you needed
because if i'm on someone's page who's
like working really hard trying to make
people laugh and trying to educate
people and i'm like maybe
like you're not well and i'm killing it
yeah so honestly i hope you
like i would be jealous of me but like
sometimes sometimes it's jealousy
sometimes it's envy sometimes it's it's
ignorance either way it's like
i don't i don't have to participate in
that with you like you're behind
have you ever commented on a celebrity's
page
only to say i love you imagine what
would have to happen to you
to come to like be like that dress is
terrible like what do you think
imagine i'm like i'm not gonna do that
in real life you wouldn't be
i can't you couldn't even get there i
wouldn't even
like if i don't if i see something i
don't like i go matthew this is terrible
and then
like i keep it moving like i'm not like
oh let me you have to hear my voice
saying that your dress is terrible it's
like what are y'all doing it's like
it's just lost you know people some
people are lost and so so get out of
there humans i know we're designed to
remember something
five times more strongly if adrenaline
and fear is involved
but just focusing on the positive like
that's sort of like how can you
say social media is dumb it's like okay
so just stop yourself being educated by
people that actually know what they're
talking about you're just gonna like
read the news which at this point is
just like which is another
it's awesome my algorithm it's all like
engagement ring ads
yes get cures about that news too i
can't with that
get i can't i'm going to get in trouble
for this i can't even watch cnn
like like i just i'm like what when
they're like and here's the thing i know
it's going to be
very controverse so a doctor was telling
me this is not my
my opinion um that uh stopping the
johnson and johnson
uh six out of six million with the blood
clots way more people died because they
stopped it
because they weren't getting vaccinated
like more people will ultimately die
driving to the vaccine to get it than
they will from the johnson johnson
not saying it's right not saying it's i
don't know that we will we do not know
the effects of this vaccine and we will
not for a very long time yeah
and uh but it was just such the media
it's like i just see them making money
off of
making us scared yes and you have to be
cognizant of that
like that the news channels
are still tv like they're still they
still have to entertain right and so
you spend your time watching people
fight each other as opposed to getting
the actual
news which is why i do think social
media has a value because you can go
right to the activists who are on the
ground
you can go right to the education this
is what i saw this is what actually
happened
yes yes you can go right to the
professionals who are just like posting
the information
and corroborating with each other you
got to know who you trust and whatever
but
remembering that like you know the
suppressors are a business
it's a business and so they know and
they make their headlines the way we
make tv show billboards which is like
make it eye-catching make sure they
click on it make sure they stay there
longer
use the most i remember i was in a i
went to school for journalism uh
at penn and you know it was like it was
always about use the most like
titillating words you know instead of
like
like um i don't know anything about
sports the florida dolphins
beat the i don't know racist team name
chiefs probably i mean i grew up with
the redskins so
um uh in dc but it was like no it
crushes them
destroys them you know it always has to
be these words that make adrenaline
because adrenaline is addictive and
attracted to dopamine and so
and also i mean neil postman wrote this
book in the 20s about infotainment about
how news
uh was was trying to compete with
entertainment and like when i watch cnn
it looks like a michael bay movie like
an eagle comes in it's like
it's like jesus like what am i watching
we're just like no we're not saying
don't watch the news but
guys do not be informed do not be
informed
only go to reddit in infowars oh my
goodness or you're new
you know but it's like cool like what
it's like whatever you watch
just make sure that you're it's not
watching you if that makes sense that
you are watching it
with a we think because i think we want
we're we i think there's also this thing
of like
we assume people are going to do their
jobs yes and we assume people would do
their jobs the way we would do this
and that's never the case most people
are not doing the job they want to be
doing
this has taken a long time that's
interesting i have this theory
about especially people in los angeles i
think everyone came out here to be
famous
or an actor and if it didn't work out
for them they're doing their plan b
but still want to be famous so when i do
like animal rescue stuff
like it's like it's like something that
runs it it's like dressed for a fancy
audition
and holding a gala where they get to
perform and i'm like oh you just found
another way
because in animal rescue you can get a
lot of celebrities in one room you can
get on instagram you can sort of like
be a celebrity within the animal rescue
world and a lot of those people
are lying god complex narcissists that i
shut the fuck down when i find out what
they're up to
but like you know like you i just find
that a lot of people are not doing what
they want to be doing
necessarily and i look at people news
and i'm just like oh yeah because if you
really wanted to get into journalism and
then someone was like
you need to make this 50 characters yes
and you need this many clicks in 20
minutes or else we take it down
yes so the capitalism of it all
interrupts the actual
work six out of six million i had
friends going to the hospital like in
their car having like panic
so scared and it was just sort of like
okay let's like
can we just calmly talk about the
numbers and just let a doctor maybe talk
about this
but it's a business and that's why as
consumers we have to recognize it is a
business and so it's our job to do the
cross-checking protect yourself
yes absolutely where do you get your
news i don't even know where to go oh my
goodness
i go to jessica yellen on instagram
she's been on the show before she has
something called news not noise she
used to work at abc and cnn and she felt
like she was lying to people she was
just like
the way we have to sensationalize news
that's already terrible
yeah like she just felt uncomfortable
and she started her own thing on
instagram and she's always got the first
scoop and it's always the best and i
just kind of go to her
because i never learned that i do it on
social media mostly and it's usually
through like the activists that i follow
or the
different accounts that i follow because
they'll periodically post different
things that are happening so it's like
if i need to
know about that then i'll get the
headline from them and then i can go do
my own little research on google or
whatever
but i don't have like a dedicated like
i'm not like
oh i have to read it from this
publication or that publication because
again business
news i'd rather hear it from the people
here from the ground even like twitter
like
you know like and i try to make sure
because twitter is it doing a thing
where
it gives you news based on your recent
searches because i was getting i was on
um
like huffington post or some shit once
and i was next to a friend on their
computer
and all my news stories were about dogs
being rescued and pulled out of like
lakes and then i looked over at her and
i was like you're not getting me
i know and then i like go to a like a
like an important meeting and i'll like
did you guys hear about the dogs and
they're like ah
9 000 people just died in a boat in
panama i'm like like i didn't hear about
that
but i do know that mickey got a home she
was saying
yes the algorithm of it all will fuck
you yeah so i was kind of like you have
to actively search out yours
and you have to also actively and we
talk with this anyway like you have to
actively diversify who you're following
what you're watching because you will
get that one lane if that's all you're
doing i'm not saying like you got to
follow you know the people who are all
right to like
that's not my i can't like get both
sides of the story no you don't need to
do that no no no no no no no no no no no
but your entertainment maybe
yes for really i watch that q a
documentary riveted oh my therapist told
me about it uh it's on my she was there
but my therapist told me not to watch
her
she told me to watch her she was like
it's uh she was like it's you know you
should watch it
it's a fascinating portrait in how
feeble our our minds are and how
badly we want to belong to a group
like i talk about terror management
there on this podcast all the time but
just like how
how alone people are and how badly they
want to just
they'll believe anything in order to
feel some kind of kinship or meaning
which i'm always interested in and
that's i think that's the performer
brain right like the performer brain
we're always interested in the
psychology of humans and so even if
they're like doing something terrible
i'm like but what
i would never do that so like what in
you
because i'm hot and gorgeous and i don't
need to work for attention and i'm so
talented and brilliant
i'm just so fabulous and i would never
you know but it's like
uh that's not how i operate that's not
moto operation not everyone had your mom
like
we have to just say like you have to
look at the upbringing you have to look
at the circumstances you have to look at
the trauma that top end and
additional inheritance that's the thing
you can look at people's
you can qualify people's like trauma and
experiences to understand why they've
done what they've done without
excusing the behavior yeah a hundred
percent and it's also i say it all the
time we forgive others not because they
deserve forgiveness but because we
deserve peace you're not gonna take my
you're not gonna take my energy because
you have ancestral trauma and childhood
trauma like that's your business
it's just none of my business like and
you lose access to me i couldn't fix it
if i tried and also losing access to me
is the kind of thing i can do for you
because then you'll have a consequence
and realize oh i have to change myself
in order to be in the presence of this
person
and um yeah it's a tricky one in order
to balance that
forgiveness but also making sure that
you're not
enabling a sick behavior absolutely or
or um trying to reason with someone that
doesn't have the tools to hear what
you're saying
yeah so i think sometimes we waste a lot
of time trying to like
whenever anyone's like this person needs
to stop being sick so it's like dude
that happened when they were two jim
saying this is like to unwire
all that like that's magical thinking
and that's part of the reason i'm so
obsessed with
people i'm crazy with all the animal
stuff but you know the research is
showing that
for the first couple years of a child's
life probably until about five
they really they don't care about humans
they just can't relate to them but
animals is all they care about
so when we take them to ride elephants
and we take them like put them on horses
that they've never met and we
let them you know touch tigers and all
the stuff that's really abusive we teach
them that anything
that is powerless and voiceless is for
our benefit and our exploitation
and we are to use something so when they
grow up and
you know anything that's powerless
voiceless whether it's
you know a woman whether it's a minority
group whether it's person of color
whether it's someone beneath them
they learn like you're for my benefit
you know it's like it's a very deep in
the hippocampus like
it's very hard to unlearn you know and
so it starts with that and then it's
like okay now let's translate this to
people humans
yeah yeah yeah you know so people are
always like why are you getting animals
there's so much
stuff going on it's like i'm just trying
to get the next generation
to learn compassion for people that are
not or entities that are not in a
position of power
you know which is like people like lions
or tigers who cares it's like well
that's what kids see when they go to the
zoo
and they're like if something is um i
was gonna say exotic you can say about
animals right yeah um
an exotic majestic animal that is really
powerful but it doesn't have a voice
it just it's for my benefit
yeah you know that's fascinating that
tracks
because how do you like there's i mean
my thing is all about like okay what
like that what does the data say works
because i think there's a lot of like
change your behavior change your beliefs
and a lot of people can go pretend they
change them sure
and that's like kind of a band-aid
solution like okay but like how are you
voting i don't know
i'm not super i'm not like the champion
of hillary i got a lot of problems with
her but
when that those exit polls happened
landslide when people went in
they said they were voting for it but
they went in there they didn't vote for
him so people can pretend
but that's like i'm always like there's
just fucking this y'all are awash let's
just focus on the next generation
sure you know because it's just so
frustrating
well i think about that too matthew and
i my husband matthew we
had this conversation kind of in the
heart of uh
like right after george floyd which was
like who do you talk to like do you talk
to
the people who want to talk do you talk
to people who are
racist and like try to change them
because a lot of what
happens is like people are like my
family is fucking racist and i have to
go back home for thanksgiving and like
i want to change the perspective what do
you mean my aunt's married to a black
guy
or that which is also like ugh that
doesn't mean that they're not racist
i'm like a surprise but it's like oh
where do you spend your time and
sometimes
you do have to realize that certain
people are just like that's not that's
how i see your energy that's what
they're doing people just want to hear
from you and go i did my work
oh yeah that's done everyone wants uh i
follow brandon check oh my goodness
that was i mean i think a lot of us that
are kind of in the the space of
education or activism
saw that decline right you saw that like
everyone's like crying with you and then
like
around august september now everyone's
like but i did that right yeah no i did
my black box yeah
yeah it's like no like these things to
your point about um
certain people it's like it's ingrained
in you it's not
changing in two months it's like you
then when it's like oh i've been
educated now i have to be nicer to
people of color
you're still it's still it's an
obligation
yeah it's still like um in your cells
like so deeply ingrained you've been
doing it unconsciously
for decades and it's not it's it's how
about this it's not your fault
how about that absolutely it's not like
intern like let's start there just so
your ego doesn't freak out
you got this honestly all you saw was a
world where everything belonged to you
and you saw your parents do it now it's
time to just like with no ego go
i benefited from that i benefited from
that unfair i benefited from that
i totally you know i i mean one of the
things i
keep saying is how have i contributed
unconsciously
right that's fine that's not in trouble
consciously there's no point in
targeting i had a friend who was like
the goal is not to hate white people and
i i wrote that on a poster i was like
yeah like
it's so wild that like half of the
conversation is like trying to
tell white people that it's not about
like no one's saying that you're
a dick and an awful person or whatever
some some are yes
but we're saying like you are doing
behaviors that are terrible
you're not conscious of it now you now
get conscious i'm telling you what it is
yeah so are you gonna keep doing it are
you gonna work on changing
so it's also like and i try to and this
is why i try to make jokes about it
because it's like you know
um between my shrill voice and you know
whatever my blue hair people are just
gonna like tune out and be like
so it's like for me i i do it through
comedy you know it's a way to be like
that's how we i i kind of know how to
dissolve the ego but like when i get a
lot of guys
um and i think this is in a lot of
businesses now i i hope people know that
when we talk about
the workplace that applies to everything
because i think hollywood thinks they're
so fucking special like there's sexual
harassment in the workplace in hollywood
and it's like you know waitresses i mean
like
it's not just hollywood and and most
people don't have the ability to get out
of their situation whereas you do
yeah i mean hollywood everyone hollywood
thinks that they're just like the most
oppressed peoples on the
people on the planet well the other
thing about that to your point is that
like i think hollywood has the platform
to speak about it but it's like it
happens
everywhere and in many ways sometimes
it's even worse because there's not a
platform to speak about it
totally not comparing people's traumas
but it's like you know i am there's
a ways to amplify certain things and you
know sometimes the
person who works in the restaurant or
works on the line in the factory doesn't
have that same whatever but it happens
happens and we have to in small and and
and whatever it is you know my whole
thing is surrender the opportunity
um there should be more white people on
tv says the white woman on tv
on the talk show just to say how can i
bring my friend so-and-so on can she you
know whatever like
drives me nuts um but uh uh what was i
thinking oh there's a lot of i think in
many fields not just hollywood but i'll
just do my
uh uh specific example um as chris rock
says the more specific you are the more
universal you are i just don't want
people to think i'm talking about
hollywood all the time
um that a lot of white men are going
like i can't even get a job anymore
oh my god and so just and okay
i uh a lot has been taken away from you
this is like a testament to how
how much has been taken away from you
that's shocking
um but also no it's that's not true you
just have to be better
you just didn't earn it in the first
place you just can't be mediocre
if you're excellent you earn your spot
in that in that job i can't tell you how
people have said to me to my
face it's such a good time to be back
to my face like it was like somebody i
knew and i was like i remember just
being like
what do you do with that is that is that
a friendship ender it is
it is for me and like and i it's not a
conversation i'm gonna have
it's just like i will delete that number
i don't need to have
yeah and it's like it's just it's just
like someone else you'll learn somehow
when you say that
to the wrong person when you get knocked
out but i i got because that's to me
to me that's uh um you know my angel
says when somebody shows you who they
are believe them the first time
so i'm always listening to people and
when you say something wrong
i know when it's different like where
it's like you're trying to learn
something
or when you it's like a belief that you
have that just fell out of your mouth
and when that happens i'm like uh you're
dangerous
and here's the other thing it's so great
to uh
such an amazing time to be black even
though
i believe the bachelor on tv last year
was i made a destroyer oh my god and
should have won
she's not like i made the best show she
made the best show on television and we
are
like she's not getting the praise which
just shows you
yeah it's like well you're black but now
we're on to native america and now
it's like it's you're you're true
it gets it still gets categorized as
just like black as opposed to no like
michaela cole yes made a black show but
she also made a
just a show it was you and that is not
it's not
like you have to just watch it but she
didn't make an amazing show
because she's black right now i'm saying
exactly
this would have been the best show five
years ago 10 years ago in 20 years
so she just made an excellent show and
it's you know it to me how how things
are playing out for her in terms of the
awards
is such a example of like which i hate
this racist trope but you have to be
like twice as good to work you get half
as far
that thing where you're like oh this is
the frustration especially as black
creators or queer creators or creators
of color
where you're like fuck you can make
something that good
and like and here's the other thing and
i and i don't know the entire story i do
know that awards are a fucking scam
you know there's also and some i believe
she deserved to win all of it but i do
know that there's so much paid and you
have to like
like for oscars you have to go to
nursing homes and like talk to old oscar
voters to try to get them and then
there's so much money behind her
there's also a good chance that she was
just like i'm not doing this rigmarole
i deserve this i'm not gonna do a dog
and pony show for you
because you have to go to all these
breakfasts and all these panels and all
these things
as monique tried to tell us years ago
i think that that's so interesting that
full circle i
remember that happening and i didn't
really understand what was going on
monique's oh god i i it's just an
interview this morning someone was like
can comedians be dramatic i'm like
monique
like what are you doing and what what
what in your estimation like how do you
describe how that all
went down you know it's interesting
because when it was happening i remember
being like
why just go on the press store like that
was my take store for a movie
yes it's about six months and you're not
getting paid yes would you do not get i
don't think i understood that either but
i was like it's a movie and
i had seen precious then she's brilliant
it's a brilliant fucking movie
uh and i wanted her to win the award i
was like they're
uh oprah is totally gonna go on this
tour i will do anything oprah tells me
to do
go on this tour girl but her thing was
like i need to get paid like this is
time away from my family
and now that i'm in any movie even a
huge mini
like that you're not getting a ton of
money i mean that was like it wasn't
indie i don't think but i think
daniel made it and then maybe and then i
think tyler perry and oprah winfrey came
on later maybe but it's like any movie
you see
the actors are not getting paid unless
it's got marvel or disney on the
beginning yeah yeah
so i was like oh and i would hear her
talk about it and i think i've
a lot of us were like girl like just go
on to the impress store the movie is
great you're gonna win this oscar do it
and let it speak for itself
let my work speak for itself right and i
think that that was her point which is
that like if i'm going away from my
family and i got to support my family
i think it would like i have to go
around the world and answer racist
questions for free
come through which which honestly that's
actually a really delicious point
because
we're now conscious in the last year
conscious ish at that time when it came
out oh my god
can you bears make that show blackish
conscious conscious
we were not having real in-depth
conversations about
race about womanhood about fatphobia
about homophobia and all that stuff not
you know
in a considerate way i would at all say
so
you're right she'll be putting herself
in that line of fire
and i think we were all like what you
should you should
uh and now in the last year just like
talking about
what is your time worth even to the
beginning of our conversation like don't
just be doing shit for free like
what is it like how dare you say no you
won the lottery it's like no i deserve
this
this whole thing of like i should be so
lucky
to have gotten this job i deserve an
added value to
you know i did my job my job was the
movie
and i think you know everybody
everyone's going to feel differently
like again i would
i mean i just got cancer but tells me
i'm doing
[Laughter]
a fart right now i'm fighting right now
you know whatever it is but for that so
i think like looking back we're like oh
shit like that that um
maybe there was a different way for that
to go down or or there is some validity
to what she was saying maybe there's a
middle ground we don't know all the
conversations or whatever but it is an
interesting thing to look at
in 2021 and she and it's honestly it's
this thing of like i mean
as a even a white woman i could never
understand
you know the stress of a black one who's
doing it it's just like
you know you um like
barely deserve to be here don't push it
you know you have to say yes to
everybody even if you're compromising
your values and you're
you know and by the way uh what you have
to really be careful with what you say
so it's like all right put monique on
the press tour and she's like hey
hollywood's racist you sure you want
that press store yes
you know yeah you probably don't even
want to hear what i have to say yes to
be a black woman nominated in this
category
inside of an institution that has kept
black people out like what is that added
pressure right
it's not just like a white man going on
a presto like yeah there's a
i think there's different trauma that
has to be
uh accounted for that i don't think we
were talking about
when that came out and she and then she
wasn't gonna hold back i mean with
female comics i just get a lot of before
you go on can you just make sure to
do that and i'm like you asked me to do
this and so when someone says what's it
like being a female comedian i'm gonna
answer honestly
yeah yeah you know what i mean you i'm
not gonna do that like well it's just
i'm so grateful
for the people that believed in me you
know what i'm saying it's just like this
person molested me
um and they work at pixar like i don't
give a fuck about your email address
what's that yeah totally i where it's
just like i can't burn bridges that
weren't
taking me anywhere they were already you
know so it's like i think
but yes to the point of grateful it's to
be grateful for being grateful
don't don't rock the boat and i think
what we're
doing now is saying especially as black
folk
uh and anyone that's not a straight
white man is like ask for the what like
speak up for you deserve to speak up you
deserve to take space
they need to pay you what you're worth
this black history month i got
approached
by i think three or four major brands
to do something for black history month
none of them wanted to pay
major like major brands and none of them
were like what's the fee didn't want to
pay it's like see that's the fuck shit
you want me to create content for black
history for your brand
but you don't have money there used to
be this thing where they asked black
people to work for free
mm-hmm there's something where they
didn't ask them
and so it's just so that that's just so
wild to me and i
it makes me so mad because like you're a
major i know how much money you have
i know how much money you make like i
know what are you doing
i dude i would scream to grab that shit
and post it absolutely well you know
yeah but shoot it to me send it to me
but it's like that thing
and that's also like the other layers of
these things where it's like when people
are like oh this will be well
you know by 21 everyone's not going to
raise this right it's like no
by 2021 everyone's not going to be
racist i mean like that's what people
were feeling in june of last year was
like oh yeah we'll figure this out
that's like white celebrities post a
black box like we're good right yeah
right and it's like
oh the same brands and the same entities
that we're saying black lives matter and
we stand with our black employees and we
stand up
are the same ones who uh seven months or
nine months or however long later
are asking black creators to create
content for free
because you should be so lucky to have a
hashtag you get to tag
us though you get you it's it's odd hour
and i i do not think you should do it
but when i first started
doing any kind of social media stuff
because i was like not graded i used to
do i used to pretend i was sponsored by
something oh
that did not sponsor me at all like i
got a couple seasoned assist letters
um because i wanted people i wanted to
show you the lie
that people were paying me to do it and
then brands would be like oh what's your
rate and i'd be like hey
yes yeah so i had to i did a bunch for
free
just so i can get paid by the way there
i do want to say that like there are two
schools of thoughts here which is like
sometimes you might do something as a
black creator as a queer creator that is
free
because you need the exposure yeah and
that's totally fine
again this goes back to like what you
know what making sure that you're
watching the news and it's not watching
you like i know you're a writer on big
mouth they know you're right on hr they
know you're paid you're not at that
point
right so it's like if you if you do need
that exposure that's totally fine just
be strategic it's a business
right for me that was like that's stupid
y'all y'all know what i do y'all yeah
look at my followers yeah but you know
that's just it just tells me how much
further we have to go
we're about to talk about magic spoon
and i've been told that i'm not allowed
to go off the rails as i normally do so
emily's gonna read most of this because
i'm
unhinged apparently and i love products
so much that i just start being like
it changed my life and now i don't you
know my
nails go grow longer and they're like
you're not legal
um but uh also magic spoon is so good my
look at all the
my dog named magic pony my foster dog
bit right through it was trying to get
to it i know if that's not and i have
bones everywhere if this isn't an
advertisement i don't know what it is
we love it so much we match our hair to
it
oh my god there's the word searching to
find words i used to love this because i
didn't have anyone pay attention to me
and i get to play with okay oh you do
the word search okay i'm going to do the
word search
zero grams of sugar 13 con that's the
first word
i saw does that say a lot about me khan
i'm a con artist except when it comes to
magic spoon
except for the brains we push zero grams
of sugar 13 to 14 grams of magic
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net carbs of i'm sorry
and only four net i'm gonna start again
see i'm just getting distracted
zero grams why are you instructed i
can't tell there's a crazy woman doing a
crossword puzzle on the back of a cereal
box and matches her hair
sorcery are you serious yeah sorcery's
in it is this a rorschach test
yeah probably zero grams of sugar 13 to
14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories in a serving it's keto
friendly gluten-free grain-free soy-free
low-carb and gmo free
we've got exciting news magic spoon has
released a super delicious new flavor
birthday cake
birthday cake oh my god now i don't have
to go eat birthday cakes in my car when
it's not my birthday anymore i
just have magic spoon or out of the
trash birthday cake magic but no i put
windex on it and then i still eat it
magic spoon will be available in special
five pack for a limited time only so get
it while you can
or build your own box available flavors
to build your very own custom bundle are
coco
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon love the peanut butter
hey if you're listening from canada a
magic spoon now ships there as well
go to magicspoon.com whitney to grab the
new limited edition birthday cake or
custom bundle of cereal to try today and
be sure to use our promo code whitney at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order
this offer is now good anywhere in the
u.s or canada but only when you use our
code at checkout
go is here you still reading yes
oh god it's so boring do you have
something you want to share well yeah no
i found
sorcery pay facts magic con and al i
don't know if that's a word did you find
i quit
godspeed said why i'm absolutely young
me
i found the word me what a shocker
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund you your money
no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
whitney and use the code whitney to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode ooh
gam love your games love your games what
are games boobs or legs
wait then on the side it tells all the
words oh my god i didn't even look at
that
i got these but they were freeballing
they have his friend wall in it
look they give you all the words to find
but i found a bunch of words that aren't
on here
so it must be all that brain food
not scientifically proven you know what
i
i i'm gonna start calling my uh i like
to spoon with my man my magic spoon oh
i mean i know you're trying to make it
sound sexual and gross but i think
that's cute
yeah you're my magic spoon so can you
please disappear from this bed
and bring me abracadabra please go away
so that i can
take this makeup off and go to sleep um
okay speaking of
you know what you should do get a a
bigger bed
good segue thank you
uh look emily thank you for trying to do
your job well i i really appreciate it i
think everyone appreciates it nerd alert
but i don't i my thing is i'm real
i just i speak from the wild and
wonderful i don't read these ads which
is why we get so many emails
specifically to reading i know and then
they're like hey you forgot to mention
this you
you literally gave out the wrong website
um article furniture i used for
real for realsies before even they were
working on our podcast with us i say
they're our partners not sponsors
right it's a co-dependent partnership i
have such bad taste in furniture
i have outside the things that i have
bought myself
have not gone well i have a giant chest
outside that is a fox a carved you
haven't seen this a carved
box it's like sleeping yeah and we will
show you a photo of it
my dog mona when she first saw it
attacked it that's so funny and tried to
fight with it i mean that's how ugly my
furniture is
that dogs think that it's an animal
anyway the point is
article furniture has made it seem
everyone's like you have such good taste
i'm like
because it's it's like i'm trying to
figure out how to describe it's like
modern
clean i like clean uh uh
scandinavian industrial modern but
not i don't like too feminine heuristic
yeah i don't like anything that's like
feels
like yeah in five years i'm not gonna
have a place for it 1000
the most amazing thing about it i'm
moving and getting new furniture and
there are so many fair prices you save
up to 30
over traditional retail prices i'm not
telling you i'm moving
articles offering our listeners 50 off
your first purchase of 100
or more you're moving out of the county
living
i'm moving out of the home remember what
did i say to you that time
this was this is not who i am but i did
say something dumb once
you were like what what did you say what
they're so
when you're like i live in some a
facility
where only everyone makes under my god
under a certain amount
that was so i lit so i don't say the
amount of money okay i lived in an
apartment where there's
in santa monica where there's an income
cap so if you made more than that amount
of money then you you couldn't live
there and i was like then
how are you going to find a rich guy
yeah and then i was like oh but then and
whitney knew that and then i mentioned
that there was a hot guy in my elevator
and she's like yeah but he's
broke and i was like so am i and you're
my boss
but also you've seen my invoices you
know that i'm broke too yeah 100
that's why i'm moving article is
offering our listeners 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more go to article.com whitney and
the discount will be automatically
applied at checkout that's article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more love you article love you
we can also be silly and dumb oh we can
do whatever and
because i feel like we never get to
really just hang out and be stupid
together so i figured why not do it on
the podcast
yeah in a place uh where
millions of people are watching uh i
found this game
it's called because i got really into it
before you i like i mean i've been my
whole new special is kind of about um
all the things we learned as kids that
we find are like completely not true
and we are the the more uh a's you got
in school the dumber you are as an adult
kind of thing do you mean like i have
all this sort of fiction in my head
so i started going through these i
bought this thing when i was in spokane
touring um because my life is sad when
i'm on the road i'm a lonely person
i went to this toy store called boo
radley's and i bought a bunch of these
dumb really dumb questions here you can
ask me one first it's like a dumb
question game
that we would probably do on like a road
trip when we were like stoned out of our
minds i fucked this up
what kind of animal is a gecko a lizard
a reptile a lizard
oh lizard reptile
yes yes excited excited
excitement just did a big kegel to hold
myself
up i feel like that was like
suspiciously easy so i doubted myself
yeah i i was yeah i like doing these
because we we're trained to doubt
ourselves yes i would have doubted
myself too it's clearly a reptile
clearly is that a geico commercial
within these little cards what type of
champagne is brute
is that how you pronounce it oh i would
get this wrong what kind of champagne is
brute
i don't know is the one with the roofie
in it they're not good
mommy needs remember why champagne i
don't know what that means
i don't either who cares oh yeah i would
get all these wrongs no but i love these
dumb little
things oh my god what's the fourth
largest wait hold on wait oh
this one i would get okay wait wait what
if you didn't don't look at it don't
don't hand them down yeah but if you
don't get this one i'll i'll
i'll leave right now in what girl group
was the singer beyonce knowles
a member from 97 to 2 000.
that is the most racist question that is
the most racist question this is not for
black people this game was theater for
whites
what is destiny
somebody's mama was like i don't know
what was it called the beyonce
[Laughter]
it was a while ago beyonce's been
beyonce for a while for a while but yeah
you can never find
but you know the youngins i mean you and
i worked with taylor tomlinson there
were a couple things she did not know
oh yes yes like we would send these like
memes to her of like waiting to exhale
and she was like what is this lady
walking away from a burning car we're
like oh
i i choked i know a lot
of things that were like honey we have
to give you a couple movies control
right
needy to watch martin what control she
didn't know janet jackson no but no
my god she didn't know uh janet jackson
uh it was i choked
she's 25 so she's she would know
destiny's child
it is weird when you hear young people
not know like destiny's child and you're
like
have you ever watched those videos i
think on tick tock or sometimes buzzfeed
does them where like
they give kids like cd players and
they're like what's this
like the kids are like
it's painful it's like oh my god
like a walkman they're like what does it
do
it's an iud i want to talk about your
show yes now
okay so the show is called the latrell
show and it's with the i am a theater
company
i am a theater spelled theater honey
um and basically uh the show is me uh
reckoning with uh the mental aerobics of
being black and queer in america but
through comedy yeah
for the most part and then you know
there's a little switch but i did it
through this character that i've been
playing for the last 10 years which is
latrell
jackson and i created that character out
of a sketch show that i was in back in
new york like 10 years ago
when wendy williams was getting her like
i think it was like a two-week sneak
peek
to like see if she would have her show
it was the best
two weeks of wait i'm sorry i was was
auditioning it like at a theater
no no it was like a new york like in new
york i was in new york i was
ra for the the tisch summer program and
she had like a two week or two month
like sneak peek and the whole thing was
like
it's like these amount of episodes and
if it goes well they'll pick up the show
so it wasn't fully picked up it was like
i have a hot take on wendy williams oh
i can't wait to hear it um the best
fucking
sneak peek of my life because she didn't
know tv
and like so there was just like she
wasn't sure what camera to look at
you know she her first guess was omarosa
and that was
woof it was it was a wild interview
but i was inspired by just how much of
herself she was
like she wasn't you know we're talking
about the golden age of oprah like she
wasn't
the polished talk show host she was
this like and when i say would talk
about
what because my hot take is that she
invented the podcast without really
knowing i guess
yes there's this casual thing where
she's on it and like
her tea temperature is more important
than any of the guests or any of the
news so it's like someone's talking
she's just like
and she gets to it when she gets to do
it
she's and people love it because it's
like you're hanging out with your
best friend yes and she will talk about
um one person even when they're
irrelevant
for an hour for weeks weeks
truly yes and i used to i'm from new
york so she was on wbl bls and i think
her like time slot was like
four to like seven and that was just her
talk she's like i'm gonna talk about
twista for an hour yes did you just talk
shit and she's just such a good talker
and you feel like you're at
like you feel like you're in the corner
with your mom and your auntie just like
having a good time and so i loved that
energy and so this character latrell
jackson came which was this
black queer talk show host which we
didn't have language for you know i'm
non-binary we didn't have language for
non-binary or
or uh in the zeitgeist you know we're
not talking about gender non-conforming
and gender the way we are today
so back then people just thought i was
in drag which it wasn't to me it was
like this black
queer uh man who wore leggings and
makeup and had a beard and would talk
shit and we called the show part improv
uh
part scripted all fabulous
so guys that's my tagline so i would do
30 minutes of hot topics which were
scripted and then i would have like a
guest on or whatever
and this was at what theater company
this was like at joe's pub arsenal
i did it at theater like it wasn't we
didn't have cameras we just pretended
that they were getting some of the best
talent that's
oh my god i'm a thousand bridgette
everett you came out of joe's pub
yes joe's pub nova dixon place all
around new york so i've been playing it
for a while and then i did out here
and then in the last four years i was
trying to write my second solo show
my first one was about like my mother
and sex and
romance uh and being gay and this one i
want it to be about what it is to be
black and queer in america and what that
experience is
uh and after doing a little bit writing
it felt like littrell was the right
thing because latrell in many ways was
my coping mechanism
as a person and i i
reckoned with my race and my gender and
my sexuality on stage as latrell
and so i created this show where latrell
is also that for
another character that's in the show
where you yesterday trial is like
helping us understand what it takes to
just exist
and be related what does it mean to be
like that fun
funny fabulous gay guy like what does it
take to be that
fun fabulous funny gay black guy and
that's so fascinating and i just want to
do a little footnote of like
because so many people you know that
come in and they're artists and they're
like i've been at it for six years and
nothing's happened it's like bitch
that you haven't even started sorry so
so many of the things that i was working
on
so hard 10 12 15 years ago there's no
such thing as wasted time and what we do
there's no such thing so i had this
weird thing happen where
when i first started being trying to be
a comedian a writer i would just like
write
scripts i had no idea what i was doing i
would watch tv shows and like just
script them out and try i read save the
cat and i was trying to figure out the
math of it all
yeah i would write specs for shows that
didn't even go
sure that i wrote in an original about
it was called 2050 news
so dumb it was like it was like about a
news uh
cen a news station in the year 2050 and
everyone was like up to their waste and
water
and like it wasn't like it was so dumb
it was just like and the whole screen
was surrounded with ads and it was just
like their faces
and you know it was always like and now
the um nascar
weather report brought to you by you
know this tornado presented to you by
geico or whatever
yeah it was just like dumb and silly and
it was like one of my first things and
then i found myself
two years ago um working with uh gary
steingard to make super sad true love
story which is essentially a
futuristic dystopia dystopian satire the
future and i kind of was like
oh my god i wrote this yes
and i literally went back to the
original and i pitched
things that i did i mean it must have
been 18 years ago
yeah and i showed them the things i made
a little presentation for it like a
space suit it was ridiculous
and um there's no such thing as waste of
time it isn't and you know it's
i think that like sometimes in doing the
show and we just filmed it last week and
it comes out on may 23rd
through june 20th you'll be able to like
stream it and buy tickets on iamath.com
oh got it okay so it's not i thought it
was going to the in person
no it's not we're not lying okay because
we're in covent and i don't want to be
in space i'm not going to be with you
so you can like you can basically rent
it for the week essentially okay say it
again
so you can buy your tickets on
iamaththeater.com and you uh they're
four weeks may 23rd through june 20.
karen i emailed your manager and i was
like i need to make sure i get tickets
let's just can you make sure
you don't go get your tickets i'll pay
for them i did not realize it was
streaming
yes it will be streaming it'll be
streaming so you can watch it
which in whatever week that you buy it
but in finishing it
last week i was like oh 10 years to get
to this
final product and it's like oh that's
the difference between being an
artist and a performer and i think
sometimes we confuse those two things
like our performer brain really hustles
to like you know book the gig and butter
and be here but then there's the artist
of you which is just creating and you
can't rush
creation you have to live your life
right imagine if they came out that came
out 10 years ago it would be trash
you would it wouldn't be well no but i
mean just in terms of like
i didn't have the development as a
person and the context of it coming out
now
yes context is everything it is and so
it's like
sometimes that thing that you're working
on as an artist as a creator
it's okay if it doesn't go right away
it's gonna go it's gonna go
it's gonna happen when the time is right
yes you know i mean i think
uh steven canales i think that that's
how you say his last name
uh pose that took forever
i went to a panel he was on and he had
written that years ago and it just came
out for
same with the lucas brothers they were
working on this fred hampton thing in
2013 was that right they started working
in 2013.
yes and so like be inspired go do other
shit but like
remember that that art that you're
working on and like hold on to it and
develop it and as
you grow it will grow and then the right
time
will happen and it just so happened that
this is the right time there's a saying
i love that god whatever you believe
higher power anything i don't i don't
really care um
god has three answers what is it um
not right now
i vaguely know this shit yeah yeah you
google that emily what is it
shit like this is genius it changed my
life
because i went into rejection as god's
protection
i love that one too yes no later yes no
not right now
yes no i don't know that's not right
that's not it did you just go to like
uninspired.org
that cannot be it god doesn't say no yes
though it's not yet i have something
better in mind
yeah yeah yeah no because we have
something about our comments it just
holds tight
that's the thing about this that i think
this industry anyone who's aspiring is
like
it it takes time sometimes yeah and
if you get a no it was probably for the
best
yes it doesn't feel like it at the
moment especially when you got your
voice and not yet let's do it when
you're ready
i've seen earlier i've been supporting
myself financially for only three years
i've been
my first professional gig was when i was
20 i'm about to be 34 in two weeks and
i've only supported myself
financially in for the last three years
so that's a lot of no's that have
happened since 20 to
31. um did you do the math right yes
whatever it is you're asking a woman we
don't know math there's a lot of
no's and a lot of rejection a lot of not
yet but you don't stop
you know you keep you keep pivoting you
keep making your art you keep making
your work i think that that's also part
of this is like
are you do you want fame or you want a
career because those aren't always the
same
as bill murray said uh uh or do you want
money so some people just want to be
rich yeah think because i was
famous before i was rich you know yes
and whatever that means i'm not saying
i'm so rich but um
i uh i'm at a lawsuit i have to settle
um i am
the amount of settlements for my staff
because i'm always naked
um it's sort of like and bill murray
said once try getting rich and see if
you still want to be famous
which i thought was interesting because
a lot of people want just to pay their
bills they're like oh wait but i also
want to be able to get down the street
yes and i don't want to be uh in
tabloids being told i've gained weight
like oh i didn't realize
i was signing up for that that's i i
think about
beyonce just because uh you know it's a
fucking stuff
but i'm always like well like to be that
like to be that famous is that what you
want where you're like you can't
like there's no existing that's a deity
though
that's like beyonce was like a is like
god like i don't know of course
something no like i'm happy to praise
beyonce
yeah yeah but i also but i wonder in
terms of again the psychology we were
talking about earlier like i wonder
how it feels for her on the inside how
it feels for people when you're
at that level where you can't really
move
through the street no out no you can't
just like say i'm going to target
no no no no without like knowing that
there's going to have to be i mean
michelle obama would talk about like you
know she wouldn't go to the target
sometimes because she knew it was a
whole thing it was like the secret
service
if i go and you want access and i can't
give you what you need you know what i'm
saying
because i walk the walk and i protect my
time
and i can't possibly and you want to be
nice to everyone you want to give
but that's never enough yeah it's kind
of my thing when i meet people
and i'm being the michelle obama of
comedy
[Laughter]
um no but i mean when someone comes up
to me and it's like i feel so grateful
to meet people because i'm like my oh
this is all i wanted all i want to do is
make
make uh money doing comedy support
myself doing comedy and doing this
and then someone comes up and they're
like you changed my life and you got me
through this whole thing and i'm like
i don't know what to do now though
because now i need to be perfect and i
kind of have to go and i have to respond
to
nine emails yes and your humanity gets
put on
what can i like i'm better on in your
imagine like i don't
know what to give you right i'm only
gonna disappoint you yeah
so let's take the photo put it in paris
filter bitch
like you got me through my cancer and
i'm like national filter natural filter
don't fuck me on that angle but that's
but that's real it's like it's you can
have the worst day and then somebody
sees you and you want to be good to them
but you're also like uh this is falling
apart over here
my whole thing is this if you know me
you know
that i'm not i'm gonna let you have two
minutes sure if you listen to anything
i've ever said
is that i'm going to be a i have a hard
boundary and i'll say okay i have 30
seconds talk to me yes
what do you want do you want a photo do
you want to talk to me do you want me to
leave a voicemail i'm like super
aggressive about
what do you need i'll make sure you get
it and then i'm out
that's a boundary that's a way to
protect your time and i think that i'm
walking the walk i'm not full of shit
yeah yeah that's a way to protect
yourself which i think is so i'm still
like learning
about and i think a lot of i think a lot
of the uh
you know the influencers and things that
got famous and covet are you know
going to experience that
that's sexy man um okay let's try to end
on a
like a silly note yeah but say the
website one more time for your show and
then
yes and the tickets are available now
and may 23rd to june 20th
these are actually kind of good because
they're tricky
they're really simple questions and i
was like i know the answer to this and i
did not
what does a camel store in his hump
water
fat
oh see we were lied to his children this
is this proves my point that everything
we learned when we were kids is a lie
um hold on why do i keep pulling what is
the name of a little mermaid in the
disney movie of the same name get the
fuck
out of her i i am her today yeah this is
insulting
um who cares about cats uh the smallest
breed of dog in the world
chihuahua no yes yes
i would have said like mini poo poo say
toy buddha that was my next
humans are so sick so when you when you
realize i know when you think about dog
breeding and the way they've bred
dogs to be so small and unhealthy and
look a certain way it's very very sick
what i don't what is the stage name of
insulting martial bruce
marshall bruce mathers iii marshall
cummings
eminem what disease known as the french
disease did al capone
suffer and ultimately die from
yikes syphilis oh what painter cut off
his own ear that wasn't even true emily
emily just told me van gogh did not cut
off his own ear he
a man bit it off in a fight okay thank
you
having a fight with another painter he'd
been working with and the rumor is that
the other painter cut it off and then
made up the story
to make him seem crazy white people lie
no way
but maybe that's a lie too who no i
don't trust him by the way and now
i don't trust anything i don't even
trust these cards these silly cards that
i paid 12 dollars
how could these be wrong uh what was
french
emperor napoleon's last name don't care
but patches told us
that uh he was not short he was not 5'3
he was actually 5'7
wow and we love to like um
how do we make him so sure because i
think there's this thing
that like we i think humans need to have
some kind of reason
for why things happen he had a napoleon
complex yeah he was just a psychopath
and that he was a tall he was not a
short
he was a taller psychopath and like
that's okay
what do you think they'll say about us
like what will they make up about us
i hope they make up something because
the truth is a nightmare for me
juicy whatever it is make it juicy
they're gonna
me i i um i don't know
like i i hope i go the full like um
hedy lamarr route like who you know she
got
she got sort of famous and was it
eastern europe for
uh having an orgasm on screen everyone
called her a whore
and a slut she was famous around the
same time as marilyn monroe checked my
mouth maybe a little bit before
came to america was a
tv star but all she wanted to do was
invent things they actually
say about her that she was like a
hollywood starlet but she would meet
with howard hughes and
and help design the airplane by showing
like birds like basically just emulate
what birds do
so obvious um took a woman to be like
why don't we just do what they're doing
um and then they say that a lot of her
discoveries and inventions
led to what is now wi-fi and then she
fucking just disappeared and went to
florida and no one ever saw her again
well that's a movie i want to see yeah
there's a documentary about it where
there is a little bit of footage of her
in florida she also apparently had a lot
of experimental plastic surgery i mean
this is my life
story um before it was really a thing
and then she never wanted to be
photographed after a certain age
much like betty page wow i know think
about it the true
like like iconic gorgeous legends
sex symbols they either die young before
you can see them all
or else they they don't never take a
picture of me again so that's always
something interesting
what are they going to say about you
what do these are i don't know that
show that show was fantastic the latron
show available
what does the ackermann ufo stand for
unidentified flying object
duh yes i knew that what color robes are
worn by buddhist monks
are they are red oh they're orange
they're orange remember that brad pitt
movie where he played a buddhist baby
i do not i have so many i am on a
rampage with old movies remember when
kirsten dunst like made out with brad
pitt when she was 10.
oh name at least one of the two flying
pioneers the wright brothers
um amelia earhart yes uh what publishing
company created superheroes iron man and
captain america
marvel these are ones that are like so
easy that makes you think you're dumb
yeah you're asking them like i'm stupid
yeah i know like i got it
what animal is stephen king's terrifying
cujo the dog
oh yeah isn't it a dog
how did the biblical judas die oh i
don't know
hanged himself like i'm about to if
these get any weirder
what's the name of the japanese art of
folding paper okay this is
origami children i did buy this at like
a toy store
are we allowed to say origami oh yeah
see here's the emerald isn't that the
name
is it origami okay okay yeah fine
i mean don't start making origamis and
salad
never never that oh my god do you think
say it again i love diet products is one
of my favorite feeds
internet calls out people that take
designs
from other people and like sell them and
make a ton of money
yeah like has receipts for all of it
which i name a couple instagram feeds
before we go
that you that i should must follow oh uh
obviously uh britney brittany pacnet
cunningham
rachel cargill yes um aloke
uh by the way brittany and rachel do
lots of instagram lives yeah they
better just like so you know i think
that i think a lot of people aren't
really
capitalizing on that don't watch
comedian instagram lives watch the
because these are
going to do more ig livestreams yeah yes
but i would have a
hey i have half an hour
sure i'm gonna this is the topic i think
it's like just managing expectations
ahead of time and like not worrying
about all the comments because when
people it's the comments that get me
you got it you know you can turn the
comments off or you can take questions
yeah you can turn the comments off
because essentially it's like someone
who i really want to hear talk getting
on being like hey guys
thank you yeah
i'm always like can you edit that out
where it starts either you can cover and
say hey everyone i'm
covering the comments for now i'll be
taking questions okay
for 10 minutes at the end i also like to
say
send me questions in advance sure i love
that on instagram stories
yeah yeah and then i can go okay i'm
answering these 10. yeah
and it's gonna be 30 minutes i love that
i tried to do i did one
where i was like i'm gonna have like
because you know do messy mondays and so
i was like i'm gonna do like a little
cocktail hour at the end and that was
fun but i haven't done it since let's go
do it a couple times and then say hey
bacardi you wanna
sponsor these i did one for um
caulipower pizza which i actually love
actually it is good matthew made one for
me once and it was delicious yeah he was
like
[Laughter]
snatched she was like wait i'm gonna
give you others uh uh
ashley marie preston yeah no rush no
rush uh the conscious lee
i love um
mila jam there's so many there's so many
how about this
go to your page and please i remember
when shit at the fan i just wonder who
you follow
so many great yeah like people like you
have no excuse not to and when people
are like oh my god instagram so toxic
okay maybe stop following all the people
yeah you hate yourself change your
fucking feelings that's it
follow that shit i'm like uh you're not
anymore yeah like just unfollow them
you people it's beautiful
okay then why do you follow 25 models
and that's it
oh so you want to talk about is another
great account oh nice i love so you want
to talk about they do a lot of uh
carousels uh about different topics
so like they like different when you
know whether it's uh
a building this week pass or a trial
that we're watching or somebody who
has been killed they'll really give you
kind of the breakdown of what it is and
here's what i'll say
it is overwhelming sometimes to just
look at your feed and go like oh
yeah so also what i do is at night i
don't look at instagram during the day
anymore
i just go at night and then i will go to
their page and take it in when i know i
can absorb it and i'm not in traffic so
it's like
model model child shot by a police
officer fashion silly
like it is like you have to protect
yourself and you have to and also just
put myself in a situation where i'm
actually digesting what i'm reading
and actually feeling it and something
well i follow this person so i must be
i must not be ignorant you know yes
taking it in and reading it and like
really processing it
yeah and not just swiping by it so fast
that you're just
numbing yourself like disassociating
yeah it's a lot
i mean i think again i think it's about
in social media and all the
and learning it's about engaging it's
about being active it's about
raising your awareness and being
conscious and intentional
about how you're engaging with these
things as opposed to letting it happen
to us
letting it and i'll flag it yeah letting
it be a marionette all of our day
because there are some things where
you're like oh god now i'm fucking gonna
go find my car
today i flag them and i go this is heavy
and i need to give this the space in my
brain that it deserves and the respect
it deserves
so i'm gonna flag all these and tonight
tonight at eight o'clock
i'm gonna go through for an hour and
read all the stuff so it's like don't
yeah don't let your feed control you
yes so that you shut off yes you know
absolutely because i think that like
right now like the biggest skill anyone
can have if they want to be mentally
stable
is like is like don't mix like the
lingerie sale
with the someone just killed you know
what i mean because then we're
then our brains do uh subconsciously
associate those two things with the same
amount of
value and which is what's so toxic about
the news yes they're like
and the um dallas cowboys just one third
series and a child has been shot today
in the street you're like jesus christ
like those
you know different parts of the brain
that's why whenever
i know something big is happening most
recently with the chauvin trial
i took myself off for a little bit
because you just know that your feet is
about to be
and you're about to see a bunch of
people like post about it to try to get
likes
yes yes yes so there's all there's so
many emotions and so like when you know
those big
moments are happening i think this is
the best time to just be like i'm not
going to be on social for the next 40
years and then you have the most
beautiful
posts about like how to process the day
off like don't think about this today if
you don't want to put it like
self-care during your time when you're
being re-traumatized the self-care is
important in all of this and for all of
us because
it's the only way for you to be
effective like nobody wants
these like fucking showy allies or these
showy whatever like i did it's like i
want you to be
exhaust themselves and don't do it for
the long haul yes
this is a long haul this is a this is a
long
there are s centuries of wiring in our
country
decades and us who have been alive and
we have to undo that that's not going to
happen overnight and so taking care of
yourself
so you can be doing it for the next
couple decades
that you're on the earth as opposed to
like i did everything else yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
such an addict mentality i wanted to be
done now
it's not happening now so take that
pressure off and it's such a selfish
place to go like i need this to be fixed
overnight because
i'm uncomfortable well a lot of people
are uncomfortable for really for a long
time
and it's going to take more than just
like a post to fix it yes yeah yeah so
we're like such a like instant
gratification
yeah i mean that's the person that just
put like stapled in nine
hair extensions before you came i mean
what is happening
do you like it is this a good look at
all i i don't know if it's a look to
leave
the house wet
[Laughter]
maybe it is like fucking i mean honestly
at this point
like i feel like this ship has kind of
sailed and i mean going back brown
i don't know i don't know what to do i
love this is my favorite color i've seen
you i mean i like all your colors but i
love
i love but the blue i didn't brush it
for like a month so the blue got a bad
did not get a good uh uh but i feel like
this has like blue
purple like mermaid vibes
i just don't give a shit anymore imagine
giving a shit
about like your hair you know what i
mean emily came in today i sprayed her
um hair pink yesterday and she was very
grumpy that it was still pink today
not my brand i can listen i'm very
particular about my hair i get my hair
cut once a week
yeah it's just like it's for me i'm just
kind of like i need
i need to stop misleading people with
brown hair that i'm
seeing and so i just like to manage
expectations
like people already know what they're
signing up for because i remember when i
had my hair was brown
everyone thought i was a bitch when my
hair was black everyone thought i was
really
nice and when my hair was blonde people
thought i was like arrogant
because they had a preconceived notion
of who i was
before i've um dealt with prejudice um
what's funny is i know you're saying
that jokingly but like the amount of
times that people have tried to like
i know i don't i understand prejudice
that's why i'm yeah just like
i have tattoos and like people won't
hire me because i have tattoos
yeah no i mean you ha gosh it's just
like they're so
yes which that also sucks i mean like
you were saying like people
uh don't think i won't think i'm saying
with this hair color but i hope one day
they will
i just want to be able to go in and just
be like i can say fucking anything and
if you
are surprised it's your fault fair
you know what you're getting before i
show up what are we talking about it was
actually funny because the last thing
i'll say when uh there was a time when i
was in coveted fog and had been taking
edibles i was in some i was on some
medical
and i remember i went to the bathroom
while we were on the call came back and
puked and you're like yeah no it's fine
like that's what i would expect from you
with this unbrushed
blue hair looking like krusty the clown
okay that's fine
you were also like in a different house
at the time and i was like there's a lot
happening you know this is what we're
doing that's a lot
a lot a lot your thank you for your
patience and we will do that
and you better get paid for that by now
for what has that check come in
you still get paid for that oh i think
so yeah yeah good yeah yeah yeah good
yeah
good good
dial-up truth really that is my life as
soon as i log off
i mean
i'm like can you just apply the natural
filter to this wait we're in person
oh my god
okay when you just disappeared in thin
air like what's happening
oh my god getting back to real life is
gonna be why i know it's very odd when
people see me in person like
and i'm like yeah i've had a filter on
my face for the past year on zoom i
blurred it out this is what i look like
okay i know i use a lovely filter i'm
not happy about it
either they see me like are you okay i'm
like no this is just how i look this is
what i look like
i love you i end these very awkwardly oh
and then pl please tell us about your
podcast
oh my podcast uh one of them is called
black folks and i'm about to actually do
another one which might come out
uh well it hasn't started yet and
treatment it's the in treatment because
in treatment they're coming back with
oozo adobe
and so i'm going to be doing the
companion podcast with dr janelle
pfeiffer
a piper um and so we're going to be
talking about mental health and
representation and black and
queer representation inside of mental
health orange is the new black i i
uh she's everything yes
i just got to watch the first uh couple
episodes of in treatment with her
and she's excellent yeah and you know
i'm
a mental health junkie uh so i'm really
excited about it it's just also it's
like wild that i mean this is literally
why the mafia exists because the
government doesn't deliver on certain
things sorry i'm pro-mafia um
like the fact that this is not taught in
schools is crazy to me
so we have to fill in the fucking blanks
yeah a thousand percent and so
that's what we're doing on that show
filling in the blanks about mental
health
we love you thank you for doing this i
will be asking you again
yeah so you're gonna have to bump it you
know when you ask them something and
you're just like bump it for a year
[Laughter]
i love you go
[Applause]